we got Marty had a really good idea oh
what target practice loser has to hit
the [__] 10t bomb 6 bomb you not pay
losers is 10 foot bomb all right yeah oh
he's down of course five yeah I'm done
all right I'll go first to put the
pressure on you what do we got [__] way
out
here fcking all right F Guns only this
one only
which one you aiming at bottom
right watch out watch out
bab hey I got three on the green one two
three four 5 I hit them all
these
M Put Your Hands Up Hit number four I
can't wait till you lose right now
car what an idea love this idea
awesome I hope you [__] I hope you're
missing those are all my sweaters too
you're just [__]
[Laughter]
done one two 3 well you already know
your gun I don't
know want to use my real I know the [__]
never used that gun before it's Marty he
brought it this morning so hold on what
was the stakes steak oh s for bom let's
go a hell no he heard me say it and
agreed you heard it right myy okay shot
[Applause]
[Music]
shot yeah know was close YouTube loves
guns YouTube loves loves guns 1 2 3 4 5
1 2 3 and then the other two aren't even
on the map because they're on the
boxes better you have a flat ball you
know that just got to get used to
it so guys let's get OG to hit this bom
he's going to hate
[Applause]
[Music]
it
perfect
[Music]
perfect perfect hey what's up gu take
the mic out of your mouth hey what's up
guys doola here Thomas whatever you want
to call me welcome back to do podcast
this is my co-host Marty O'Neal what's
up guys and we're back with Lil Rob's
brother this is OG all right OG's
back yo we didn't take 2 and a half
hours to start we weren't here at 10:30
in the morning wait OGG I definitely
don't have better aim than OG as you
guys can see from this
intro had guns for 30 years I'm over
here bro I don't shoot [__] little
plastic little balls man I don't shoot
easier
stuff [__] little ball goes
up all mine went straight that was cool
so let's start off this episode
um you almost blew your own foot off
we're talking about a lot of stuff
before we started this show and then we
need to start off with that we did the
whole episode before the I know I asked
this guy like you ready he goes yeah let
me roll Two Joints 38 minutes later we
started really what time is it's 130 man
how is it Marty you got here an hour ago
1:30 my boy he had to get ready yeah
yeah I R those joints 11 had to set up
11:15 I've been ready it's okay you blew
your foot off
go what foot what foot wait what foot
what
story you got to wait minute oh it's
crazy you just told the story but you
need to be reminded is nuts oh when I
say I almost blew my foot off about your
gun right now yeah oh [__] [__] you mean
what you were talking about right now a
second ago there's got to be so many
little stories of OG's that would never
come out without the right question 100%
like it'll never it would never like
always dud even with my friends and they
say some stuff like what oh yeah I
forgot about that that's right I'm going
write that down I forgot yeah there's a
lot of story so you almost blew your own
foot off and your child and a guy in a
wheelchair
continue [__] all you do was ruin a
bunch of people's clothes that's all I
heard no I almost blew my foot off
[__] uh what with a [__] uh 45
Desert Eagle how though [__] uh so
this was back [__] I think this was
when I was
what maybe about 21 years old I think 20
years old 21 I think and uh [__] um
some [__] I went down so I was like [__]
you know I need to get me a big gun so
[__] it I got me a desert eagle I came
across the de Eagle so [__] it and I was
[__] around came across one that's 21
years I was [__] around in the room
[__] with it like [__] well you know
still not that I was unexperienced of it
but I was just like [__]
unexperienced but I was just [__] I
just said you know what [__] this let me
see what the [__] you know I mean cuz
like I had other smaller guns and [__]
you know it's like go damn this
motherfucker's big you know like a big
ass you know big [__] that [__] let
my finger on the trigger boom pop that
[__] yeah [__] uh [__] Dam that [__]
[__] uh you C with your finger
already on the trigger yeah and it went
off instantly went off boom and I was
like what the [__] [__] I just
[__] see that I shot downstairs I was
like [__] I was living upstairs [__]
ran downstairs cuz I had one of my boys
downstairs who lived and the food was on
a wheelchair and he lived underneath you
know his room was underneath my room I
go [__] I hope I didn't [__] kill
this fool [__] went down there I
knocked on the door and his sister
answered like oh yeah and I'm like is
everything all right I go somebody just
threw a bottle at my window and she's on
really it sounded like a
gunshot somebody just broke glass on
glass I know it didn't sound like glass
on glass go I go somebody threw it right
in my window but they threw it in
between my house and your house you know
between the apartments you know she's
all like yeah no we heard something but
no nothing we didn't nothing
everything's good down here I'm like all
right I'm a this [__] uh is uh they
called him I think uh my boy T-Bone I'm
like is T-Bone all right he's like yeah
T-Bone's in his room watching TV all
right cool [__] it next day I [__] I
see the fo out there smoking a joint I'm
like what's up fool everything good yeah
and he goes oh I heard you came down
somebody threw a bottle [__] at the
[__] window joints that yeah they did
and he's like [__] fool he's like sound
like a gunshot F because I could have
sworn like little [__] came falling off
my
roof stuckle and [__] they put CU some
[__] came falling and all then that's
when I told him I go n f I'm G tell you
what happened you told yeah I told him
he's all like [__] for real I'm F like
on my first thing was like I thought I
[__] probably [__] shot you fo cuz
you know was a [__] big caliber he's
like [__] I'm good he's up but yeah
some little white [__] came down off my
ceiling I was like [__] so was in the
same room as him um um yeah actually I'm
upstairs and he was downstairs in the
same room he right underneath me you
know cuz the apartments are they're all
kind of form he had a hole in his floor
too no no he didn't it like it just
stopped stopped yeah it weak ass bullet
you know and then my girl just gets
there and she [__] looks at me what
did you do and I'm like nothing it
smells like smells like gunpowder and
I'm like oh no I don't know she like why
you look all pale and I'm like oh [__] I
just thought I killed the neighbor
that's but how how far away from your
foot was The Bullet Hole on the floor
[__] bro I'm talking I would have blew
my I swear right now I wouldn't had a
foot right now I swear my [__] did
you see the video of the rapper last
week that got his [__] foot shot by
like the dude fio down in uh Florida got
his foot they put the picture of his
mangle foot yeah oh wait when he blew
his [__] foot off someone shot him
shot him right in the side of the inner
foot like the like right where you step
on the sole there's a hole in his foot
this big you see straight through his
bones no way it was disgust this dude
still a zombie no he was going to the
hospital it looked like a zombie foot
movie oh so this was right after it
happened he showed it yeah cuz he's a
rapper you know you're going to take a
picture of yourself getting shot the
second he get shot yeah yeah yeah oh
damn yeah I got to post this call 911
like what you doing call 911 why you
post
it he call it's crazy dude it D that's
some local [__] I did see the picture
I'm telling you a hole his foot this big
okay pretty got a chill between that
Gore and what the the hell they just
showed me what happened what did we just
see describe this video I got on my
Twitter cuz OG was taking nine years to
roll a joint I got on my Twitter and the
first thing that comes on my Twitter it
said from fun viral vids that's the page
it was a guy skydiving with his dick out
oh
yeah from the back skydiving with his
dick out from the back I see like a dick
coming between a guy's leg like what is
this is he [__]
oh he zoomed it in what is that yeah I
zoomed it in can you zoom on Twitter I
don't know probably probably huh that
was not why fun viral vids that's what
you that's what you suggest me the I
watch fights yeah and in terrible [__]
you think you want completely uncensored
[__] until you get that on your home
screen yeah we all want uncensored till
you see a dick [__] that's the title of
this episode everybody wants uncensored
till a dick comes into
play That's How porn started all right
here we go what you say apple juice two
two types of apple juice some apple
juice I got two different types of apple
juice one frothy one not yeah one shake
and the other one I don't what you got
on them
Jays dud I got some uh I got some OG
right here some heavy IND [__] my boy
tried to see if he likes it my son's
very picky yeah you seemed like you were
kind of like upset that he was so upset
last time or whatever so you brought
some [__] fire hey go you know what
I'm going to bring some [__] fire for
this [__] guy right here cuz this
guy's always [__] complaining
no not impressed look at him look at him
all right well let's see hopefully this
does I hope it's fire I [__] hope so
he's brought me one fire ass strain like
three months ago in the first time in
four years which is nuts La is not doing
wait what about when went to Vegas we're
smoking the whole way up there you live
that
OG you you weren't
complaining on the way to Vegas we were
driving to Vegas [__] made me smoke
almost all my weed I was like [__] yeah
I got some good weed out of nowhere this
[__] we're smoking place I rot
another one and we're like [__] all a
sudden I'm like [__] bro this guy's
smoking all my OG we drove a lik it yeah
remember oh for Champs yeah all right
we're supposed to fly out there and our
our flight got
cancelled that's not what happened so we
ran into a van you hate flying so do I
that's why we didn't fly just trying to
make it sound good man [__] no no we're
honest we're honest here I can dunk on
him we're honest out here do like how
bad do you hate
you know what um I just I thought that I
hate it but once I'm on there I [__]
it's like getting a tattoo you know you
want a tattoo and then once you started
you're like oh [__] I forgot about this
[__] pain all right [__] and that's
the same way I feel on the plane like
once we go up and I'm just like son of a
[__] what the [__] am I doing up here M
[__] did you hear [__] this [__] the
story about the co-pilot trying to take
down the plane bro I would have started
bombing on him the second they [__]
walked him off are you kidding me wait
what did you try doing a [__] pilot
tried to dip a Southwest flight into the
ground and his other pilot had to
wrestle him off of it what do you mean
dip he tried to kill everybody he
freaked out was like [__] this tried to
dip into the ground and the co-pilot had
to choke his ass out call the fire
marshal they had to [__] arrest his
ass he's getting charg with 82 182
counts of attempted murder that's right
[__] piece of [__] [__] get a Bad Day
by yourself a [__] bro I I mean I
literally sometimes when we don't land
right I [__] dog the [__] like
horrible [__] Landing bro you know
[__] out of here you know and they'll be
like oh you do [__] it you know [__] you
you know what I mean and you know when
they do some good Landing I'm like [__]
good job I feel so grateful to be alive
when we land I would never think about
harassing the pilot I'm just dude well
my my first experience [__] on a
plane was when I was like eight nine
years old bro and we're on our way to
Puerto on a family trip with my whole
family and that's back then back when I
was 8 years old I mean that's when you
could literally smoke on a train I mean
on a train bought all tickets for you
that's a lot of plane tickets well I
mean mean [__] my dad [__] did
[__] you know he did work hard so
[__] I mean that's the only vacation I
remember going
on one vacation when we were on we were
kids and that was it you know but
[__] I remember we went on a plane
from uh TJ to [__] ptoa and God damn
bro I mean I was a kid I really didn't
give a [__] you know I I didn't know
what the [__] going on but I was
seeing and feeling everything was going
on and I was like God damn that's some
[__] local [__] but yeah there was
still um remember my dad was smoking a
cigarette
you know and [__] my uncle in the
back was smoking A [__] roach by the
restroom and I was like God damn my dad
kept [__] taking shots taking shots
taking shots I didn't know why well yeah
they [__] finally told us oh put your
heads [__] in between your legs put
your heads down because [__] you know
the we're dropping like 30 feet 50 feet
down boom boom 50 feet 100 feet boom
it's hard yeah bro we're just dropping
boom and we're like what the [__]
going on I was just like damn you know I
was a little kid but I was like damn so
I see the [__] they dropped the mask
on the little mask came down [__] and my
mom was breathing it and the l l oh are
you doing are you all right and the
ladies and my mom's like yeah I feel way
better she's like oh you do but wait
it's not even on yet she turned it
on you know what I mean but hey boy it
was it was [__] wild it was a wild
[__] it dude that [__] traumatized me
[__] for a good minute and we still
had to fly back we still had to fly like
about four more planes after that damn
so you know what I mean but luckily all
the other [__] flights were cool as
[__] so I was like all right cool but
[__] what what do you expect on Cortez
Airlines what do you think your kind of
fight you're going to get what the [__]
that was I think some wild [__] bro I
was like God damn bro it's a wild ride
but you know of course [__] once you
get you to destination that's it you
forget about that [__] [__] it half you
forget about it oh [__] I don't I go
[__] four more days I got to get back on
yeah I didn't think about it like that I
just thought about it like you know I
think I was just a little younger that I
just really didn't give a [__] at the
time bro if I die I die bro who gives a
[__] right I didn't have much going for
me at the time I didn't have much going
on no businesses just a kid you know
what I mean [__] it it is what it is but
that was my first experience on a
[__] plane bro and that [__] was
[__] wild man wow wild [__] it's the
70s or early
80s in Mexico what did they give you for
food I got to know do you remember what
you ate on that plane in the 80s in
Mexico when you could smoke a roach on
the [__] flight um say they had TV
dinners yeah we were at the store
yesterday looking at TV dinners like a
[__] TV it's been a long time since
i' seen those a [__] little steak
with the gravy old school [__] you
know that was Mom I mean I didn't eat it
Plan used to be like a party back in the
day they had [__] they were doing
drugs and [__] oh bro yeah bro serious
my uncle was smoking a roach in the back
bro and I'm thinking [__] who the [__]
Smokes on a plane and back then they
would allow still in the ' 80s people to
smoke cigarettes it was more like a
hotel experience I think right it was
like yeah come on and have a good time
while you're on the plane versus like a
police state style thing yeah yeah it it
was pretty cool can I take a quick piss
off are you [__] kidding me got take
a piss guys I got to go PE we're 9
Minutes in the last one you know when
you got that little last one bro that's
all right promise to
be don't be mad he don't smoke joints no
more he pees 60 times a day well bro I
wouldn't want to Dam tequ I would have
been all [__]
up what you just broke the SE now oh my
God broke
the it's been minutes it's been minutes
you break the it's you're going can I
get the lighter I gave 9 minutes ago
thank should just [__] film this from
that room in there and [__] right give
me your bb gun I'm shoot him right when
he walks in just [__] pop his
ass since I said it I just said it too
last night no he brought Candy I'm like
[__] I just surprised that candy
actually wasn't 10,000 milligram he just
[__] got us well he would never put
that much effort into putting [__] and
it's hate seing it
again it was easier yeah you don't eat
anything it ever bring that didn't cross
my mind so right now there might be weed
in there yeah you might be
careful y podcast sick I said 15-minute
podcast yeah we're really at 15 minutes
and he had to
piss crazy and should in on
the oh my God
Jesus
Christ guys get at least
questions hey don't kick the camera I
got you my boy yeah they're doing shifts
like a hockey
team all right my B ready nobody ever
left beep you still haven't let a joint
dud yeah there you go hey man what's
your favorite TV
show TV well God damn we don't watch TV
no more what was my favorite TV show I
mean
uh [__] I mean from what year we're not
going to get an answer cuz I mean no no
I mean [__] any Year bro give me a year
what year year overall
overall what I like [__] I mean I don't
know I like old [__] episodes [__]
you know [__] uh Married with
Children [__] [__] thre company all
right [__] you know different Str I
watch all that stupid [__] from back in
the days Strokes I mean that's mother
for I watch TV since Tak me back it
takes me back to my time so it's like I
feel [__] I feel like in a comfort
zone when I watch [__] like that you
know what I mean yeah of course but
that's that's fine yeah it's all old
school that [__] start you don't watch
anything new what about you reality any
any genre reality tv that you watch uh
like I watch some Netflix series and
[__] like that you mean [__] um like
a real world he's talking about the real
world Jersy sure reality TV oh reality
TV no I mean [__] I watch my own [__]
yep I knew going to say that like I
watch my blog I watch my son right here
watch my
blog yeah watch you no he doesn't stay
up on all the latest episodes no he
doesn't he didn't he didn't know that we
made a post for him today till he was
sitting here and said oh you posted it
when I was at the liquor store when I
was buying a beer I was like oh [__] I
seen I had like followers like oh damn
what's going on here I go damn what did
I do last night and it was Mio for made
the only fans do even remember
I so faded off wine what did he text you
first thing when we got here we're here
getting ready I called him twice this
morning I'm like ah it's okay he's
supposed to be at 12 12:30 it's 11:40
it's okay then he text me 11:42 a
sleeping
Emoji [__] ass [__] with him what a
[__] get the [__] out I to [__] with
them you know all right press the button
press the button that shoots him into
the air we have the [__] air
compressor under you go
at the end of the episode I just this
gets his head stuck in the that one man
sitting on the tire remember that's what
that's what's under your chair that's
how we end the show with you damn you're
really lighting the [__] out that one
without no fire touching it it was crazy
you saw it the lighter wasn't even on
was [__] touching it my boy all the
[__] is this [__] on then my
son weird saw I was looking at him like
maybe's just trying to like really
softly burn it like this yeah I was
thinking in my head like he's like this
like an artist that's I was looking at
him like what is he doing oh he's not
paying attention Okay
okay you like that you like that wheat
it looks like it's burning good already
yeah it is might have to have I want you
to ready go like this I'm going throw my
joint in your mouth go like this let me
blow OG's mind real quick and yours too
because we didn't realize there's more
to it you know what this is surv a laser
it's
a is it a laser it's a thing from men
and black we're gonna make you forget
that you're you're supposed to be what a
flash what flashy thing from the Men in
Black it raises your memory remember
[__] it's called the day pipe from our
sponsor Hamilton devices look we thought
it was just four little bowls right here
interchangeable it's eight it's eight
what the [__] bro different strain in
each little bowl real quick OG so you
literally have it loaded up though no oh
[__] I was let's check it out let me
check it out check this [__] out I
thought this might [__] blow your we
were shocked by this [__] honestly very
[__] I mean I mean it looks a little
kind of weird but I mean it looks like
something you would insert into a
human nobody no reaction at all [__] it
does [__] dildo look like [__] we
didn't want to say nothing but I was
like okay like we didn't want to say
nothing I was like God damn oh [__] oh
you scared the [__] out of me I didn't
even mean to do so put on evil laughter
looping in the background oh you don't
have
headphones damn you packed the [__] out
of that Marty you will never get to the
oh never mind you will get to the ash I
take it back no I take it back you smoke
hard you ever seen Marty smoke a bowl
look at look at him oh wait no no he
does
this and he he he summons all the lung
power of his family tree and [__]
kills BS dude remember Mulan where
they're like yo we're going to protect
you all Marty's [__] family comes out
it's like yo get that [__] drinking
keyston for real Like a Lion
King He just a bunch of every instrument
any [__] family member play you
finished that [__] already crushed it
bro the thing is a little tiny little no
no no it's not it's not he put half a
bowl got eight of these things loaded up
wait till you see this hit a
bong see this will hit a bong bro it's
like watching somebody beer bong it's
like they put every [__] physical
piece of energy into that to make sure
they get it all out and like it's true
it's like it's full do this I know Marty
this
one you hit a bun every time you go cuz
you're trying to conserve the fire not
hurt it not too much and like [__] and
then you're disgusted cuz then I go back
and rip it after the initial exhale
which is to me I was like shocking that
people don't do that no people do that
people do that I used to do that a lot
it's
just I think once you smoke so much weed
you're like I don't want to taste that
stale ass
smoke it's like yo I love tequila oh
it's
warm put in fridge uhhuh they
essentially like flip that bowl over is
put it in the fridge for us now last
week we talked about Thomas's horrific
Bud rot issue that he had oh yeah yeah
oh yeah bud rot but he was saying that
even back in the day you were a botanist
out with your microscope examining I
talked about the first time I met you
went to sell this full packs 12 years
ago to sell this full packs and
uh busted out a a [__] microscope
over his eye looking at a nug of depths
the [__] were you doing this was trying
to humor me is what he was trying to do
he was trying to be like I got to let
this fool know that I'm serious but also
like does he know that these are there
was a lot of [__] going around that time
you know what I mean there was [__]
lot of PM SM that PM would hide real
good sometimes so I'm like I didn't give
you a [__] oh you were hitting something
as oh sorry I say bro I didn't give you
a [__] joint are you serious you were
actively smoking a joint okay that's why
I didn't do it okay my bad [__] my bad
[__] when you say DS Light deprivation
Greenhouse uh the stuff in the the tents
that you see outside that are clear so
you can still get light but they're not
they're indoor that are outside it's an
ouse okay [__] inside you put the
lights on sh inside you know it's tap
and half it's half light half fuing
sunlight okay yeah the tarpet there's a
lot of weird methods people people do
it's good [__] but just at at the time
there was a lot of so much [__] going
around bro that seriously throughout
that whole day everything I was getting
had [__] PM had [__] bug bug mes
or had some [__] [__] on it so I
was like [__] this I'm [__] insect
and I'm I'm going to inspect every
[__] nug every butt I get now
starting today and I started just
[__] just checking everything on yeah
I mean [__] still like that n not no
more because I mean no I mean [__]
people got the eye now too yeah and you
know not only that but I mean [__]
now I only [__] with certain certain
people and I say bro I don't [__] around
with [__] different people no it's
all just in the circle now I don't go
out of the circle anymore what's got to
happen to get you guys super like what
means to happen for it to go back to
always being having fire um what
happened was Instagram ruined the weed
Market ruined the weed Community ruined
the sales and gave everybody all too
much information too fast is what I
think you can't tax the kid from New
York anymore the kid from New York came
over here and dm' one [__] that
was willing to put his neck out there
yeah and now it's over we just chargeing
for 42 now we can't charge a 42 you
stupid [__] because one guy wanted to
make [__] extra 2K [__] it all off
for everyone and that's why nobody gets
to sell weed anymore yeah no everybody
got their P everyone's connected it's
not the same no more the game has
changed gone over oh it's over yeah
imagine the music industry yeah same
thing happened like oh it doesn't work
that doesn't work anymore that is
nonexistent the radio is Black Market
Black Market sells yeah I guess but
everyone the second people started
shooting and robbing each other over
[__] five pack was
over it used to not be that way the game
Chang you know like even now like [__]
there's no [__] it's not like before
[__] you see a celebrity and you're
like oh wow [__] you see a celebrity
gives a [__] I don't give a [__] nobody
that's cool you know that is true
everybody more normal nobody cares no
more like before you no giv a [__]
nobody cares at all no it's the internet
I got to be honest it's just the
internet guy put something up his ass
and [__] smoked a joint or something
got famous for it for 30 seconds
and then two companies gave him 10 bands
because he was really popping at the
time or someone did something so
insignificant then in three weeks you're
like that was a meme I thought this
guy's on Ellen yeah why the [__] is he
on Ellen or what was the the white shoes
white Nikes the white van damn the damn
Daniel remember why the [__] is Ellen
interviewing the damn Daniel
kid it's a [__] sixc clip and what
happened is it made everybody go oh my
God these viral people they have
something to like no they don't [__]
they don't the second they don't make
money they're not going to do this [__]
not they don't give a [__] yeah yeah
it's random so what happen celebrities
went why is David Dober so much more
famous than me I'm Brad Pit how come
these kids give a [__] about him I used
to get swarmed at the mall now nobody
gives a [__] it's because nobody really
gave a [__] they just realize now that
oh I never really
cared and now it's like oh go do my own
life [__] cuz you notice like a lot of
Internet stuff is like kind of it's kind
of stagnant right now
yeah there's no there's nothing crazy
nobody's like damn you see this [__]
full [__] like even I'm watching [__]
like it's like everybody everybody
expects a sh see [__] like that already
it's not nothing shock even now like
[__] I'm even like I'll be on [__] uh
Twitter now and [__] I see some crazy
I'm like [__] okay I mean nothing
unusual you know what I mean you see a
fool getting [__] his head blown up
or sh oh well [__] what sad actually
sad I don't know what you're talking
about that's make you do go like oh no I
mean the [__] you they be putting out
there you just see it so much now that
desensitized to to violence I get that
exactly I'm talking about content like a
a Content perspective yeah yeah yeah no
but it's almost the same [__] I you're
say mean well you're right because it is
content you're still sorry content
creators yeah sorry they're still
putting it out there as [__] content
and [__] yeah yeah so I I don't know I
feel weird and it's the same thing with
the weed Market what happened two
celebrities got a weed thing they
[__] post a video and it look like
8,000 people showed up but if they turn
the stage behind there was [__] six
people in the crowd but they made it
look like that cuz they shot between two
shoulders and had the [__] artist
look at the C I know how to do this [__]
I remember I told you like I can make
one of those Candace Cup videos in our
house with four homies just get close
shots have enough hands to move past the
camera as I pan into dabs and all
reality I film for my phone and there's
four fools on their [__] iPhone Kevin
mallister thank you the Kevin mallister
I can make it look like the house is
real give me a cut out of Michael Jordan
and I'll give you budget I'll get you a
promo out of you that's what happened
like everybody was like I charge for
promo I charge for promo I do this but
they didn't do anything yeah you know
what I mean like how many uh internet
people came and went that were like oh
it's 5 Seconds like why the [__] are you
interviewing these
people every time they did that they
watered down the the sponsor's view of
advertising for sure that's why we had
to stand up when we thought South Rogan
was stealing our [__] it's like had to
say something can't come I mean there
was multiple reasons why but one of the
reasons why was you can't come just yeah
on this [__] brand yeah cuz it would
have watered it down completely oh yeah
and then [__] six celebrities that
hit a joint a few times now have a a e
show where every thumbnail they're like
this with red eyes and [__] you know
that would have happened you know that
would have happened sure if Seth Rogen
[__] was
successful bro get ready for nine other
celebrities I feel like yo one time I
did
acid like damn one
all right yeah that's all I got like
[__] you're a celebrity so you'll pull
it and that what happen the sponsors
come in and once the sponsors come they
look at the fools that were doing sh
forever and go Seth R he's so much more
famous than you guys but yeah but but
who cares you know yeah but that's what
happened it watered down to make
advertisers go I don't give a
[__] like you're going to pick the
internet kid over like once again Brad
Pit because he's going to get more views
and [__] that comes in but even though
that's not that's not sustainable Brad
Pit [__] Interview with the Vampire
this is sustainable you know what I mean
I can watch that movie over and over
it's only so times I can just watch when
your baby mom's just real mad at you man
oh shut up [__] it's only when so many
times a skit you can put a wig on and
play the other [__] character it's
only so many times I can watch this [__]
and and everybody decided to do it and
that's all and then music and the
rappers started recognizing putting them
in their music video it was like when
Eddie Murphy would put you in his music
video because Rick James because you're
the man it's like yo those are two Top
Dog mother [__] right there in the
same video and now it's like yo
it's it's the mon stars and the Space
Jam teams of Internet creators yeah
what's up guys taking a moment from this
awesome episode to talk about one of our
brand new sponsors this is raw papers if
you didn't know raw papers is the
official paper of the dope as usual
podcast first off shout out to them for
believing in the show thank you very
much so what you got to do is go to your
local head shop your local smoke shop
and get raw papers there but if you go
to the shop and you notice it's not
there tell them them to reup go buy more
stuff go to hbi International if you're
a store and you want to check out
wholesale hemp composite plastic
Grinders yes they're plastic but it's
made from hemp kind of like chichin
Chong where the whole car is made of
weed same concept raw has so much more
than papers there's every single smoking
thing you can think of when it comes to
rolling they got up next this is the
first paper I fell in love with this is
what I rolled through Instagram the very
first three years was Kings siiz
Supremes and then as everyone knows the
cone these are gigantic boxes of raw
cones if you can't roll they have
rollers and they have cones so remember
go to rawthentic.com every single
product they have the information they
have everything if you want to donate
you want to do charity thank you so much
to raw papers for sponsoring the dope as
usual podcast back to the episode I got
this OG I want you to try Thomas don't
hit it I'm gonna put it out too [__]
ass haven't tried the OG yet well I
usually wait wait for a little bit make
sure and I'll relight it and I'll hit it
oh I'm relighting I'm hitting a relit
joint
you just you
literally I'm saying what if it changes
my perspective on
[Music]
Itor you should be good you almost shot
a handicap man it didn't
you yeah it's a little heavy you even
listen to me you almost shot a man in a
wheelchair and then you look look at the
tip why did you do that oh what what did
I do you left all the grinded weed just
sucked into people's lung oh that's the
what it's supposed to be look at the tip
that means there's no reason for it he
just made a straw this is a straw man so
you want that that's why I've been
that's why good hits you know what I
mean can you [__] plug it up supposed
to have a little W in there there's
nothing in it hold on I'll pinch it no
nothing will come out did you get weed
in your mouth I'm about to this no you
won't trust you won't that [__] so
sticky and [__] so sticky instantly
weed fell out when I flipped
it how could it not bro that's because
you [__] inflicted it the wrong way
pick it this way mi
see okay you almost shot this man that
in a wheelchair didn't care it all ruin
Mindy's clothes put your child in danger
oh yeah the next day she woke up and
she's like she got her pants and her
pants had a hole through it everything
had a hole through it the socks had a ho
through it her underwear all her clothes
that was folded right there went through
all her clothes you know what's funny is
OG's just standing on folded
laundry I don't give a [__] that Min
already folded these clothes I'm going
to stand on it and shoot it no no no it
was like on the side so I had like but
if you think about it you were just
standing on F put the [__] away she
wasn't
home she just had a baby she got home I
had my little daughter like two rooms
across I did I did my little daughter
was on swinging on a little swing [__]
you know like yeah my little daughter
she was [__] doing the dishes and
[__] this was was elabor she was sh it's
not like I [__] went by my daughter
and went [__] [__] the [__] and
everything I knew [__] I knew [__]
all right so here I go let me just
[__] I want to [__] see how this
[__] Works cuz I was used to
just having little small caliber
[__] it was a [__] Desert Eagle
it was [__] it looked pretty bulky
and big so I was like [__] let me
[__] let me see this [__] yeah you
know I'm [__] went in out and Kaboom
[__] I love it cuzz every time I look at
you you say something I look at me she
goes she's right there to reassure me I
love it don't [__] say that it's such
a good
she's what it is you know what I mean
it's not like I went by my baby and
cocked a gun I didn't say that good
good 6 months earlier you were on crack
cocaine naha I was still on cracked at
that
time I was man
[__] yo can you put title crackhead
nearly kills daughter and wheelchair B
man then covers it up no my daughter was
totally safe I knew she was in like
[__] in my living room so I knew
where so you know and I wasn't like
pointing the gun sideways saying oh yeah
Point [__] down [__] down I almost
blew my foot off that's for sure
wouldn't had a foot right now for sure I
would have had at least I would had at
least a good [__] I would had one
[__] to the standards of living back
then were nuts but yo my man yeah he's
on crack sh that's crazy to think about
what the
[__] OG right now I wasn't a CRA I said
I wasn't a crackhead like that you know
I was a crackhead at the type like [__]
it when it came down to the weekends you
want a party that's when I'll be like
[__] it let me get some this [__] [__]
yeah not nothing like [__] Monday
morning or Tuesday I'm like [__] I'm
feeding crack hey man the days of the
week are very important when it comes to
crack exactly it was like Weekends Only
You know [__] weekend only man drink
[__] it take had no job only on the
weekend bro I was still on [__] I was on
W for a mon fact was on
Ware government assistant crackhead
nearly shoots [__] wheelchair I was
only getting about what were gting like
600 $695 $700 a [__] month government
assist and that was a lot of money at
the time you know what I mean at the
time how much back down cuz rent was
only [__] 600 oh really yeah and what
yeah it was only 600 for a two-bedroom
[__] you know and and [__] um [__]
I had a roommate [__] it I ran him a
room for [__] 500 so I was only
paying $100 for [__]
ran you know what I
mean scamming the [__] out of their
homie just so he can smoke more crack it
is what it is my boy I just love the way
you know what I mean I love how he
played it off with his M or whatever
like the door yeah a bottle bottle like
a bird [__] bird well it sounded like
a gunshot well no it was glass on glass
you're wrong I did someone threw a Bott
my [__] window and she's like really
it sound like a gunshot I was like or
she sound like a like like a pop she
said and I was
like I go no it was a bottle she oh no I
go hey how's T-Bone T-Bone good oh he's
in his room watching TV or he's in his
room Ling oh okay cool I can see the
scene and OG doing this looking over her
how's how's T-Bone oh yeah good yeah it
was a bottle it was bottle and all right
I'll see you tomorrow goes upstairs pale
no I ran back upstairs you know I was
all right cool [__] everything
through the hole in the ground I just I
was just sweating maybe my neighbors the
side of me probably might have called
the cops but I was like [__] it I is
going to happen we're cool but then
[__] My Girl pulled up and she's like
what the [__] what the [__] happened I'm
like nothing she smells like [__]
gunpowder I'm like a desert eagle goes
off and no one call the cops you got to
get out of that neigh man goes off in
the house and no one said [__] apartment
building Jesus Christ why don't you just
look through the hole in the ground if
your homie wasn't on the floor dead you
not you can see the [__] ground
[__] guy the laundry was in the
way yeah exactly what do you mean there
was a rug there was all kinds of [__] I
didn't [__] go and put my you know I
put my finger I put my finger through I
was like oh [__] okay went down [__] ran
downstairs as long as I knew everybody
was cool downstairs I knew we're good
upstairs I'm on [__] it I could [__]
I could beat the rest I don't give [__]
cop comes I don't know what the [__]
you're talking about go to the other
[__] house maybe they did something
everything's good here put laundry over
it straight up yeah you know if you're
in a movie you got to fold it but the
only thing that was a giveaway was [__]
my girl did smell the [__] gunpowder
she's like what the [__] is that I'm
like nothing smells like gunpowder I was
like [__] what she she didn't even know
was gun powder but she said it smell
like [__] Fourth of
July we [__] the way it smell like
when we light all these [__]
fireworks that's what she
said some [__] when I smoke weed like
this [__] Tes like fireworks
smoke that's what I mean like sulfur
like chemical like yeah yeah it stinks
that's what I mean when like oh that
tastes like fireworks smoke I don't want
that [__] it's cuz that F didn't
flush it right I think it's funny
because yes fireworks smoke is
distinct you know it's firework smoke or
smoke on in your
house I was like [__] it it is what it
is you know what I mean was that the
first time something cuz it's like no
you know what actually you know what I
think I might I was just probably Stone
and I just [__] didn't [__] you know
think about it no I was I wasn't smoking
crack I was just [__] Stone your
finger naturally wants to pull the
trigger you got to like fight against no
no I put I left my finger on the trigger
I did and when I cocked it in and out I
had my finger still on the trigger and I
[__] po it popped on me mean yeah I
know so you know not only that but like
you know I'm not going to lie [__] I was
still young [__] I think I was only
like [__] 20 years old 21 20 years old
bro so not that I didn't have know I I
had little straps and [__] little 25s
which it was the same [__] but you know
[__] just [__] that you know [__] bro
when you're on the streets ain't nobody
nobody taught me it so much like oh [__]
this and that you know [__] do this
it was more like bam here you go [__] it
back you're good but and that was just
something like a mistake that I [__]
did like [__] that was stupid of me
Common Sense should have told you that
you know that's why like when I was
first given a handgun you know Common
Sense like yeah of course don't [__]
even on the [__] trigger but you know
[__] I thought oh [__] it's a big ass
gun and you know I just wasn't thinking
I was like God damn bro I [__] this
is [__] big yeah you know how's this
[__] going to feel when it [__] lets
off and well [__] I felt that
[__] bro he called me right
after he's like Dad Dad Dad can you
patch holes on the ground like don't
worry son I'll get some carpet I'll get
you some new jeans I had me who in the
bathtub yeah I was in the bathtub what
is that I was like nothing me it was the
opposite this whole memory is trash in
Spanish Spanish backwards that's why
[__] little rubby ducky right
there rubber
ducky rubber
ducky [__] out of here Jesus Christ hit
the weed or something you didn't even
smoke it and you pass it to like that
[__] up right now when I'm done right
now I'm not done with with the food
smoke that let me get a fan question all
right let's give him a fan question
something we got a couple good ones here
hit the weed you owe me a six foot bomb
r no don't trip I got because my aim is
impeccable bro come on you gave me a
little [__] plastic gun with a
[__] both shot with it orange tip on
it you both shot with it though okay big
shout out to a. 650 who I must have went
to chat GPT because they came with
literally a list must have wi the chat
GPT I love 10 good questions oh [__]
from one person
yeah this is a speed round we don't need
crazy elaboration OG I know you're not
listening at all see I knew you OG this
is speed we're going to show all right
this is a speed round fast question not
speed we were going to ask you questions
fast and you answer them fast you don't
need to talk a lot about each answer
just say it got you all right there I
don't know how to break it down clearer
than that I was like you know what no we
should said it I did say it we're just
going to speed these questions off and
you go mar mar Marge yes no Bart Simpson
just answer them whatever the question
may be I don't know what the question
we're start them off easy here all right
all right let's go one superpower for a
day what would it be and why [__] this
is the
question I think I was as as [__] uh I
think [__] uh being invisible I could
being invisible oh sorry we talked about
it when we're were in that Hill that
house in the Hills being invisible
somebody talked about it and then I
would be one of my greatest cuz with
that devious no told what if he get hit
by a bus or hit by a car because nobody
sees him no but you could see it's I
know you can see are you go in front of
a bus right now no but [__] happens I'm
just saying like it's more dangerous for
this
guy texting and [__] people to see a gun
floating just think about all the big
glasses think about all the Biggest
Secrets think about all the Biggest
Secrets I can find out right now in the
world there a gun glasses flaing around
you know I see the Photoshop right now
it's just glasses with some gloves think
about just think about everything you
could do think about L find out
everything show up to every event Marty
and say you were there I swear show up
to the baby shower okay swear to God I
was there like where where do where do
all these like like let's say anything
you want to find out let's see [__]
[__] all right where are all these
who are the Mobsters right now [__] it
let me go the ones that are running
Vegas let me go [__] just stand
around hear information [__] this team's
going to win this [__] it I got me some
money I know who's going to [__] pull
it off this okay still ghost is a crime
he Som still goes to right [__] it yeah
well if you're going to Pi invisible
it's got to be for criminal I'll be able
to [__] save the world too right [__]
man which what are all the top guys of
the [__] FBI watching [__] it let me
go [__] see what the [__] really on
their mind since I'm invisible how you
going to get there bro Drive get you
can't drive a car you're invisible no no
I'm not no you're for you know a
superpower that I can have me and I
could be unvisible and invisible okay
I'm sorry I thought you meant like
you're just invisible no that's like
that's what that would do no you can
turn it on off no turn it on off that's
cool man always invisible right that's
why I said it yeah so I know I don't
know oh you mean I no okay so you mean
you meant like a a superpower I could
just have on me all the time sorry guys
misunderstanding compl no you're right
this is a complete misunderstanding and
you're right
I thought you meant like you're always
invisible stupid no hell no why would
you want that like okay well I mean
superpower I mean [__] I think that that
there is scaring Mindy all the time
popping up invisible was a great answer
I would say if any superpower I could
have is going to be power this F would
use it 100% to watch the Super Bowl for
free by the cheapest ticket he'd walk up
to the field that this is the kind of
[__] that this man will do walk out on
bills May the ra maybe the Raiders will
make it to the he just walks up and
pushes the the ball a little higher
exactly he uses all his power for the
Raiders hey [__] right when it say hi
kick the ball what the
[__] their stadium becomes Just haed sh
you know I'll tell you who do you want
to win tonight [__] you want the bills
to win tonight I got you my boy well
that hold on that goes into another
question here from 510 Janie how you
feeling about the current situation
surrounding the Raiders and their new
coach and all the [__] going on with
them you know what um I'm okay cool bro
with that [__] you know about these
these F come out saying oh I'm from
Compton I'm [__] NWA [__] out of here
bro I don't want to [__] hear that
[__] Bro [__] win some [__] games
bro Goa [__] that [__] bro we heard too
much of that [__] [__] already bro
saying all the I don't understand the
coaches I thought they came up they say
yeah okay well I'm from Compton I'm
[__] uh listen grew up listening W
who gives a [__] bro we don't [__]
want to hear that [__] bro want to
[__] win already Bro [__] it it's not
like this is our [__] fifth year
[__] and okay cool we want to hear
[__] that over over 20 [__] some
Years bro we don't want to hear that
[__] [__] out of here with that [__] you
know what I mean it's plain simple
[__] win let's [__] win baby
that's it [__] all that [__] I don't
want to hear that [__] Raiders suck damn
they suck sorry [__] it a great a great
answer great answer you know all right
go back to that guy's list of questions
okay cuz I kind of like that this is
cool this is cool cool if you were a pro
wrestler what is your persona and your
signature move called
the signature move is like fool I'm on
my way I swear I'm right there I'll be
there right
now that what it is never happens never
Happ you're just waiting for the
move he checks his phone four
times does this hey fool six times and
that's the move you get so bored it
forfeits okay I don't know no [__]
He's not going to give you an answer
that's why I gave the answer there's no
way in the world he's going to give an
answer I mean okay I don't know I know
uhuh well all right well something to
think about movie God something to think
about he's going to go home what would
my wrestling move
be my window St up at the stars at night
we put it how oh [__] how you put it on
silent I watched it happen sh
I got to drop from my work real quick
yo is this a bit hey what up man is this
a
bit all right cool hold
long six okay did you [__] your pants
again top of the bottom did you [__]
your pants again bottom all right cool
top of the bottom got Pasqual did you
[__] the pants did you [__] all right my
boy just came through the soundboard
remember when you [__] yeah we heard
every word you said
remember when you [__] answered your
phone and then called somebody else in
the middle of the podcast my bad this
guy it's cuz I you know what it's cuz of
what hey bro I got these quarter Million
Dollar Rooms getting dropped off I got
to [__] make sure you're not even at
work [__] you're your day
off this day off hey Pi up no don't
speak Spanish over
here sh [__] how you say sh [__] my
pants in Spanish [__] the [__] out of my
pants
[__] what's wrong with you man my
just got to we good we all
good remember that one time you drank
multiple kinds of apple juice answer
your [__] phone in the middle of the
show Almost shot an elderly [__] or
he's doing great with these answ though
so we can let that slide can't we let
that slide can we oh the bong rip I give
you is going to be [__] disgustingly
fat all right all right that I got you
you got to finish it oh [__] ruin
your whole day I feel ugly give me a
[__] drink I'm going to make you
throw up does all the time oh [__] my
bad she be the last one my bad my bad my
bad put your phone on silent my bad I'll
be silent after this one my bad how was
it not the first time yeah this is crazy
Mindy are you calling him and [__]
with us dude put on Sil so that was just
fools checking up [__] I be getting
[__] calls every [__] morning bro
and I call back these numbers and
they're all you just answered a number
you didn't know well I thought it was
somebody cuz [__] I just answered a
call so I thought okay [__] someone
else is calling me let let me know that
they're [__] on their way too which I
already took care of it boom no it's a
[__] the people that are [__]
checking up on me where the [__] I'm at
put your phone on silent you want to
hear something trippy though put silent
let me say this though check this out I
[__] put tape over my cameras bro no
phone calls at all not one [__] phone
call this man might be [__] hysteric
took those [__] tapes off F now my
camera's are visible I [__] get a
call every [__] morning throughout
the every like about five calls bro who
the [__] is it I don't know y tape on
the iPhone yeah yeah I take my [__]
iPhone up [__] yeah bro hey [__] if
[__] Steve Jobs did it you did
kidding me yeah I appreciate you can see
the [__] shit's not [__] look it up
Steve Jobs used to put a [__] [__]
something over his little cameras all
cameras all the time bro yeah I don't
think that's a horrible idea I mean yeah
you just answered a [__] number you
didn't even know who it was in the
middle of the [__] podcast and it
wasn't on silent no now it's on silent
so don't you sure I put on you want me
to call you make sure just for you let's
make sure just for you let's make sure
sorry guys this is not a podcast this a
conversation in a [__] garage I did
cuz your friend he's making Dr legal
drug deals and shital drug deal the [__]
man is it going off it it was legal no
you haven't even called me I'm called
it's actively called what happened to
the voice see see what I mean h it's
[__] some weird [__] look it oh now
there you go okay fine sound what
happened to a boss you have a call no no
no that's when I get a Tex text oh my
[Music]
God [__] hit the hit the airbag on
him [__] throw throw him into the
ceiling bro this is crazy what kind of
airbag who you lucky I don't got it
loaded
up holy [__] we pissed within 14 minutes
answered three calls and one question
you've answered one question but three
calls you're here your ratio is [__]
terrible are you ready yeah I'm ready
are you sure that you're ready let's go
on to another question hopefully we get
through it are you sure you're done with
your [__] phone calls on your day off
I mean I hope so bro I mean [__] how
about this just don't answer them uh
give it a second you know yeah you're
right you know what the last one was
[__] [__] but ain't that a
[__] some weird [__] real quick okay
okay now we have to do something real
okay are you ready I'm going to ask you
this next
question no I'm not not asking that cuz
that's never going to no you know what
ask it all right what is the strangest
food combination you've ever tried and
actually liked it the strangest food
combination uh being on time to a
restaurant is that strange to you no
actually you know what was weird I mean
I not it was
weird H maybe [__] putting [__]
mayonnaise on my [__] saich that's
[__]
disgusting I'm going to be honest that's
that's exactly what we're asking OG
pretty BM and then you liked it that was
the exact question you [__] answered
the two-part question right now [__]
good [__] you know what feel good you
know what I'm not going to Car Bomb you
right now I was going to [__] ruin
your car right now for three calls are
you ready if you could swap lives with
any fictional character for a week who
you know what no no no no just keep swap
lives like meaning they'll be able have
my life stop I'm I'm not going to even
ask it stop I had to stop having with
you I mean that's going to have to be
Miho right here I'm going give Miho
right here it said any fictional
character anybody that's fake if you can
swap lives with anybody that's
fake H [__] yeah of course Superman
there you go done perfect done [__] move
on [__] okay I can't ask this one either
cuz you know oh my God what is oh you
could ask it if you could no we only
have 7 hours of footage to fil you'll go
for 9 hours on this one yeah go for it
if you could oh my God if you could time
travel to any era past present or future
where would you go and why bro you're
really getting deep into these [__]
question I'm going to have to go back to
my [__] Mayan days to see what the
[__] really went on with this [__]
Christopher Columbus so you're going to
go back and watch the spin-off of Sons
of Anarchy the Myan uh you're saying
you're going to watch a show Sons of AR
you fool no I'm going to go back to
[__] in time see what the [__]
happened 201 when the see where where
did we [__] up where did all this big
[__] up started at see who really [__]
we're going to go back and it's a bunch
of Fools and sunglasses and headdresses
look just like [__] OG and
everybody's putting everything off and
like you fix it now you fix it now you
fix it and you fix and the whole city
fell apart that's what the [__] happened
that be dope do you really would you
really picked the that's what you're
going to use your D that's cool I guess
I mean either that or I would go back to
where we [__] first started
when they say Adam and Eve that's where
I would go back to what if they're just
[__] bitching at each other we go
back in time they're just like [__]
fighting over each other you eat that
fck no [__] you stupid [__] I pay the
rent here you eat the [__] oh could
you
imagine I like that and then Adam shoots
a [__] hole through his apartment
floor all right let's I would really go
back to those days maybe the dinosur
days [__] it be [__] in the land of
the
L running from man this is crazy you're
answering questions though you are you
want to go run for your life is what
you're saying you want to go [__]
almost die yeah you L yo there's no way
any dinosaur that if they're real or
they're fake whatever it is if they we
would die by every single [__] one of
them yeah I'm pretty sure you wouldn't
survive maybe a day not one would we be
able to pass couple hours oh I can't no
I want to do like what you did in your
trip where the dude was guiding you and
looking at things but they couldn't see
you but you got to actually be there I'd
like to do that through all those
different
oh yeah that'd be sick you can just like
watch it oh [__] yeah all right ready
you're on a deserted island and there's
only three th you're on an island by
yourself with nothing else and you can
only bring three things what would the
three things be and they're not humans
oh well for sure you know weed like what
like just some weed or like a lot of
course what do you mean like three G for
no for as long as I I'm there I I'm
kidding I get it here bring me a crop
I'll grow weed there then oh there we go
now you're thinking and that's how the
May started all right continue yeah
that's how my and then one started
taxing on the other and then it just all
fell apart go second thing uh second
thing would be we what a good first
[__] answer and I'm going to say
[__] just some good water and of
course after the water good food what
else [__] what else could you possibly
do to live food water but and
weed so you described three things you
have at your house that you do every day
yeah I thought you going to be like well
if I'm on an island I mean [__] what
else are you going to do I mean if
there's no food or water you're [__]
then you're not going to live that long
on that island I I would say like a
plane and enough gas to get out of there
that'd be my first thing no was and or a
speedboat
no I'm kidding I'm kidding that's what I
would have did like you didn't say I
couldn't leave and go home [__]
[__] oh this is a good question go
for it not evil not mean not getting
over on somebody not taxing somebody all
those are out of this what's the most
hilarious prank you've ever played on
somebody or had played on you not taxing
not being mean not shooting at someone
nothing like that
prank uh giving uh probably giving my
boy [__] some [__] uh some uh
xlx
you know giving him some xlax and then
forget that I gave him xlax and he's
with me at the [__] had the [__]
uh swap me shade on
himself and what I KN I [__] did it
to him F [__] that had to buy had to buy
him some clothes I had to buy him some
clothes at the flea market okay so this
was one the [__] uh this was a dude
that uh was doing bad in in in Mexico
you know and he was on meth really bad
bro so so I [__] you know we brought
him back on this side and you know
[__] try to you know get him clean so
yeah he cleaned up all right he was cool
but you know after a while he's sober
about eight months later he's sober he's
back to himself and you know he's trying
to be cool now now he's trying to like
yeah I want to drink beer I want to be
cool now you know wait man you want to
take some [__] some [__] pills
food these are downers you know call
call him [__] some P wa getas and
he's like s so you know [__] it I give
some [__] some they were xlx they
were
blue tell they were [__] you know
downers and [__] yeah he [__] took
him and then before you know it I forgot
hey fol let's go to Swami let's go
[__] to the indoor Swami let's go
right here
[__] when end there the next just out
of knowwhere like oh I'm like what he's
like oh my stomach I'm like okay
whatever F I'm still licking that
clothes [__] some pants he's like I
need to go to restroom and [__] f
for he knowed [__] I'm looking for
him everywhere [__] where's this F at
you're annoyed yeah you know cuz we
don't have no [__] cell phones or
nothing there you know there a '90s so
I'm looking for him all over finally I
go to the restaurant like know you know
used to call they called him cholo I'm
like
Cho
he I'm like what are you doing hey you
get me some pants he's like [__] on
myself I'm like what do you mean you
[__] on yourself first I'm mad like what
the [__] what do you mean he's like yeah
I don't know bro he's sorry bro but [__]
you know and then I thought about like
oh my God bro what the [__] did I do you
want crack is that what you forgot
[__] yeah no
[__] I was smoking crack I forgot about
dude how premeditated was this like did
you plan this out or did you just come
across this bro I just came across the
[__] like in the moment yeah and I
said [__] it let me go to this you know
what I mean like you know you go get a
glass of water and you're like oh [__]
what XX [__] you know what I mean [__]
[__] let me tell dud wants some
[__] this bam he took him [__] before
know I forgot about it he trusted me
yeah so I was [__] you know so yeah f
[__] do [__] all over himself the
thing is like new pants that doesn't fix
it no I bought him some [__] I buy
him shoes bro he [__] on his shoes too
socks I got my whole outfit bro I walked
out of there with the whole [__]
outfit bro you're making him feel all
like belittled in [__] like really bro
dude came out [__] like with the new
outfit and [__] we got in the car bro I
remember we got in the car for one and
I'm just like you smell like [__] still
smell like [__] poo tell of course no
yeah no of course I told him go God damn
bro I bought you new clothes you still
like [__] and he was just [__] like
no did you tell him you gave him XX no
never told him to this day never you
still know him uh you know what yeah I
could possibly still see him in the film
yeah for sure he's still connect
connected to the fam for one way or
another yeah well I hope he sees this
for sure you embarrassed him and scarred
him once he heard his nickname he's like
[__]
yeah [__] [__] great question what
a [__] [__] hey man you
stink I mean that's a prank that I
probably pulled off that I could still
laugh at but I pulled a lot of other
[__] bro I'll tell you right now I put
off some crazy [__] yeah that's not the
but you know you don't want me talking
forever
worse but I mean I mean they could
probably be worse or maybe be even she
don't want me talking forever I like how
he throws it back on me yeah bro I can
go on forever gave us a coherent [__]
story [__] I've done one full paragraph
15 episodes hosting the [__] [__] up bro
you started off fine you started off
great and then you was like I got to
piss you have to go piss one more time
bro you said that was the only time no
no no I might have to piss one more time
oh not right now that would be the last
time he said the last time
what other pranks did you
pull [__] bro no no no no no what other
pranks did you [__]
pull [__] okay that you can remember in
a full story right now
though if not we'll move on I
just I learned my lesson for the past
three or four episodes that I got to be
like yo I don't know here's the bumpers
for bowling changed these [__] PS
back here I changed a few [__] for
Easter I [__] um think we had conf
eggs and I went and switched them off to
real eggs so people throw them at each
other yeah people were breaking real
eggs on top of each other's heads for
minute for like about maybe 2 three when
they all figure out they were all full
eggs they were giving to the kids
[__] eggs and [__] what a piece of
[__] I mean that was one [__] did you
saw this happen no mind I wasn't with
Mindy I was still a kid bro oh you got
to set that set that I thought you were
K but I was about 15 16 so I was a
little [__] I thought you like
recently oh no that's [__] that I used
to do back in that's that that's funny
that's some [__] that's what Chucky
changes the bullets in part three to
real bullets and gets all the kids
killed this F Chucky yeah you hear me
switch it off [__] um did some
[__] dumb [__] Bro [__] Switched
Off oh I think I said it before on one
of your shows when my [__] roommate
kept [__] stealing my roaches that I
would leave you know at night that I
would smoke I would always leave a h a
joint in the morning I you know I like
to come back to my Roaches for some
reason [__] the Hit Me Harder bro you
know what I mean it's resined up just
[__] hits me hard go inside play a
game so I would go out there be like
[__] son of a [__] my roach is
gone and this food would leave in the
morning every morning at 5: in the
morning so [__] this [__] one day you
know I got chili and [__] put chili
and everything [__] oregano [__]
got it smoked half of it you really
smoked half of it well not smoked and
held it but just made it look like a
roach you know what I mean made like it
was bro you yourself you know what I
mean [__] put it back right there put
it back right there and [__] you know
in the next [__] morning F I swear
bro not even to [__] bro but I woke
up to this [__] coughing and
choking in my [__] balcony bro
because he was [__] smoking my
[__] chili joint that [__] that I had
put chili and Oran CH Jo [__] it was
[__] choking left choking left
walking down I literally looked out my
window what the [__] that this food
coughing choking walking away Bro [__]
and he [__] yeah he took my [__]
roach I'm like yeah [__] why
don't you just keep the roach inside n
because I left it right there where I
always eat my roaches you know what I
mean I was I would go out to my balcony
smoke my smoke my joint the night half
of it yeah I had a balcony to my
apartment no this was when I was still
in my Apartments when I was living
before I moved to the pet no I get it
but like you shared a balcony he can go
in there too well it was a balcony that
was outside you come outside the door
you had a balcony I thought you you had
to go through your room goon everybody
everybody could know just my like we
could go out to a balcony my neighbor
called go to his balcony to his side my
was my side he's dipping into the public
astray yeah and I would leave [__] my
[__] like on the window right there half
a joint and I'll be like [__] he it's
gone it's gone what the [__] it's gone
again and so this will come out 5: in
the morning look out there and look like
where my chair was at and be like oh
[__] roach so like oh this [__]
[__] it bam here you go fool glad to
hear other people are smoking ass out
that next Stu he was [__] up I think
he came home from work and he said his
throat was [__] up I was like yeah
stupid you just been like yo hey you
know that's my have a joint oh man let I
let him know after smoking your roaches
let him know after a while I think he
knew what the [__] he did you know he
knew he just was waiting for me to tell
him and I think I I think I ended up
telling him a couple years later like
yeah [__] you're smoking my [__]
remember you're taking my roaches did he
keep doing that uh no he never did that
after a while cuz he knew what I did he
knew that I caught on so he knew like
[__] he might have maybe even opened it
and said what the [__] am I smoking of
course but got him fool that's funny got
him fool yeah I [__] got him bro you
know what I mean oh that's that's a good
one you know a lot of instead of just
being like bro can you stop smoking
these [__] you you're like you got to
go to mental Warfare now you've entered
into this
[__] yeah cool I [__] with them that
that and then uh [__] I remember I
got my dad one time I put a [__]
little firecracker in his [__]
cigarettes you know he was pissed how
I'd be pissed too he was
pissed and it wasn't like a piss like it
was funny bro he literally [__]
literally wanted to [__] me up how old
were you I was about 15 I was like oh
different [__] a thick head [__] him let
me put a [__] cigarette a [__]
firecracker you at the time I was like
he's a [__] you know [__]
youngster you know your [__] pops
wants you to [__] be straight [__]
you up and you know it doesn't you don't
want be gay B [__] you man that and then
that was that one and then after I did
that one F literally like 3 days later
we're in Mexico and I [__] did a hoe
on his [__] beer and he took a drink
and he was SP
oh that's a good one and he thought he
thought like something he was even
touching his mouth like [__] okay he did
it again and [__] and he's like what
the [__] and my uncle's like what the
[__] my uncle's like they're drinking
with them they're like what's wrong man
what you spilling beer on yourself and
he's like I don't know fool and on the
third one he did it and boom and he
looked at the [__] can it had a hole
and he looked at me and you know all my
uncles everybody thought it was funny
we're all laughing and no he didn't
think it was funny he didn't do [__]
because I was a little I was like 17 or
but he's like [__] think you're
[__] cute doing stupid [__] still you
think you're [__] little kid and I
was just you're still [__] doing
stupid [__] on his like [__] it yeah am
apparently it's crazy you called a
different guy Dad it's weird to hear him
call somebody else that isn't that crazy
it's it's odd I was wondering if you're
going to say talking about Grandpa here
hold on hold on hold on hold on do you
remember how I got you at the Rainbow
Room do you remember when I pranked OG
at the Rainbow Room which you don't
remember huh no I have it on four years
ago today Snapchat I have a screenshoted
on my hard drive what was it which one
when we rolled up mad joints of raw
Rainbow Room you smoke weedu I already
know [__] idiot he gave me a [__]
french fry stupid ass I had this supp
smoking a french fry for 30 seconds like
[__] man [__] this [__] Li man I'm
[__] dying laughing on the other side
of the table I rolled up hell joints he
rolled P joints I put a french fry in a
[__] paper and rolled that [__] so
perfectly it looked like this but it's
just a french fry
inside cuz it was kind of soft and I'm
like he's not going to notice I mean of
course at first I'm like all right cool
but I'm [__] distracted talking I'm
like all right we're all talking I'm
like what the [__] I'm like [__]
I'm the only one at the table just
staring down at him like [__] yeah and I
got him on Snap trying to light this
[__] and this Fool's like this it's a
[__] french fry you could hear him
like when the realization was everything
for me uhhuh the fact they took 30
seconds was nuts like hey it's kind of
heavy solid it's a solid fry yeah it was
it was I just thought like [__] it's a
big joint it was heavy as [__] it's a
french fry compared to a joint you know
what I'm saying but I put a filter I
twisted the tip that's like he does look
it's like one of his joints that was
good yeah you got me that was good all
right I will say that all right did we
uh did we ever get OG side of the story
from that clip we just posted on the
Cliff's
channel from the uh the ball that you
guys went
to oh
[__] oh thank you we might have talked
about this with him on an old episode I
don't know but you
ready what's your perspective walk us
through your night remember when we went
to that remember that little [__] I
used to work with old white fool little
[__] [__] oh yeah remember he took
us to that party in the warehouse for
the Wii company the [__] the [__]
weirdos go you walk in what's your night
we get out of the car meet him we're
about to walk in that weird building
where they're like give me your phone go
well it all starts off I'm like all
right we're going to this party cool
we're about to get up I'm like uh Thomas
can I take my gun no what are you leave
it in the car leave it in the car and
I'm like [__] bro are you [__]
kidding me I'm like [__] all right [__]
it I leave it in the car going there I
said all right cool we're in the line
[__] oh we get your email and you
need take a picture we're like oh okay
cool after that okay we're there's
another dude on a desk sitting there
like just a plain desk [__] you know
nothing around us we're like okay and
you behind this a little [__] nice
little [__] little pouch bag that put
your phones in there what the [__] l m
we and him look at each other like what
the [__] you know like come on who the
[__] it's a warehouse you cannot [__]
bro you know we're tripping over like a
phone like damn all right cool we put
our phone there we go [__] we go up
these little [__] winding ass little
stairs some old school like Mexican like
Mexico stairs like the ones they got you
know they got little stairs like that
[__] little sharp little stairs that
you could [__] break your neck if you
[__] whatever we go up to the top and
all sudden we're in the room [__]
like the brick wall we're like okay so
what are we doing here okay now dud we
going to push on the wall we push on the
wall bro [__] open opens up into like
this [__] bar restaurant weird [__]
whatever we thought it was cool at first
we're like oh [__] it's dope we're like
damn this is cool all right cool we sit
down oh would you like like some drinks
and [__] I'm like yeah can I get no we
don't have oh these are our drinks I'm
like God damn what is this [__] every
[__] drink was like seemed like if it
was made like with a [__] Fireball
you know what I mean [__] you know
spicy [__] right like cinnamon hot
[__] [__] you know like liquid
cocaine like there's a drink called
liquid cocaine and you know it tastes
like that [__] everything tasted like
that red pepper flakes on one of them
yeah the [__] I'm like what kind of
drinks are this I'm like I'm not
drinking this [__] you're like oh we got
some uh pomegranate wine or some kind of
[__] wine well [__] let me get that
you know what I mean whatever [__] we
I'm drinking that bunk ass [__] you
know and then after next thing you know
they come out they're like okay guys now
we're going to [__] everybody's going
to get up and we're going to switch
seats and we're going to you know like
it's like switch seats from your partner
and [__] you know what I mean I'm like
what the [__] I look me and this looked
at each other right away we're like [__]
out of here fool we're [__] switching
seats everybody switched seats except
our table we all sat there still we're
like fool what the [__] and then you
know at the end this dude comes out no
not even at the end so he comes out he's
like all right guys go ahead you guys
want to [__] take eat whatever you
guys want to eat and [__] if you guys
want want to give somebody something
they could eat it or some weird [__] bro
you know go ahead and put it in your
body and whatever makes you feel good
it's what makes you feel good weird [__]
a great story right now so I'm looking
at this F I'm just like okay you know I
was about to get the little play and Fe
my meole I was like here eat this you
know what I
mean like all right but it was some
weird [__] Bro [__] weird you know
what I mean so after that we're like
okay you guys want to talk to each other
and ask each other's questions and [__]
I was like [__] I was like all right
well [__] we're still in the same table
so we're like you know right I'm not
going to ask my son nothing weird here
ask him a weird question but that was
what it was [__] it but yeah it was some
weird [__] Bro way off [__] way off [__]
finally we're just like let's [__]
get the [__] out of here bro so you guys
left early oh oh we left before yeah bro
started I think there was a [__] orgy
after that it was like a dinner there
was only like 30 people four of us
[__] bounced before it even started
yeah for sure I don't I think did your
weird friend leave there or he stood
there he stayed there hold on yeah you
told that's the best story ever told
best story you ever told I you walked me
through that [__] so well you are dead
on right in every aspect you didn't [__]
up anywhere I was waiting for him to go
and then and then this bro that's not
the same night no you crushed it said
ver you said Verbatim what I said except
the brick wall remember what it was it
wasn't the brick wall that move
it was the two doors when we left the
door and brick wall moved so the brick
wall yeah the exit was different
remember were like wait we came in
through here but now the door's over
there okay what the [__] is this yeah
that was like in case you triy to run
off [__] you probably would you probably
would have ran off the wrong way the
wrong [__] way into a warehouse yeah
it was it was a it was a building built
inside of a
warehouse oh it was one of those those
like almost like a set uhhuh yeah you
said that [__] and he says you want to
put it in your body or in anyone else's
body whatever you feel comfortable feel
free I went I am [__] out of
here I can't wait to leave and the thing
is the guy we were with I worked with
him I show saw him every day we all get
up like we're going to move and change
seats and I went like don't go anywhere
I think we all play musical chairs we
went around our chair we moved and then
the [__] idiot I'm was working with
looks at us
like [__] he moved and didn't see my
signal like don't go anywhere he's over
there by himself with five strangers
that are down with this party everybody
there was
like thank you can I get another drink
like what you don't feel for your fear
for your life you don't give a [__] if
you get penetrated by anything here I'm
got to get the [__] out of this place
and I'll jump out this window if I have
have to it's only one floor MH and dude
like the main [__] like the
main owner of this whole [__] company
came out and was like gave a Hunger Game
speech yeah exactly same [__] yeah some
[__] weirdo [__] last one wins I
swear to God he came out with a tight
ass suit
like walking like [__] Mark
Zuckerberg and [__] he was creepy creepy
nice guy I met him before how there's
going to be so many of
right now there's one it's Saturday
afternoon you think a bunch of Rich
fools aren't [__] having sex each
other [__] there's a bunch of people
Bing each other right now in a [__]
mansion somewhere in a basement or out
in the Hills behind a picture you have
to get into the [__] Building without
behind a [__] picture I'm telling you
bro unnecessary oh come on people are
weird also that was such a good [__]
you told that story well that was
perfect exact go back and watch your
first episode and then watch yeah the
first one the first one was like when uh
you're trying to send a text on a bumpy
ass car and you're like trying to get
through a conversation but the guy keeps
going hey you should just just text just
text you're fine just text and that's me
shited yeah and you're drunk that's
pretty much your first episode I can't
watch you
fo glasses got bigger and covered your
face remember that yeah I do I do
remember see you're doing better apple
juice it's great this amazing is there
any more fan questions cuz that was a
[__] great that was a doozy of one
wait you know what um you don't say I
have to piss I mean I was just going to
say this should be the last one oh I
knew you were going to say you have to
piss just before just I mean quick I'll
be back quick don't worry about it just
go ahead keep talking and I'll be back
you got to not stop you have to piss
while walking and then walk back sure
you're all right good now oh yeah for
sure that's it say usually when I drink
certain B of beers Spears make me
crazy
stupid [__]
idiot stup all you ready are you ready
yeah I'm ready son I got a question for
you all right let's go let's go I feel
like you're this is the moment to ask
you this boom budget is
there you don't have to worry about the
startup you don't have to worry about
the building's there all the stuff's
there you need to spend a million dollar
a million dollars is there for Budget
what separates you on your weed company
or your company that you're starting
versus everybody else that's in the weed
Market cuzz you see a lot of companies
right now you see dog [__] you see good
[__] you see people that know how to
Market you see people that aren't don't
know there still Market on MySpace you
know what I'm saying like you see all of
it you turn down companies every day
they're like bro this is not going to
sell and you can see why so you're
gaining the knowledge of like you're
basically an expert in cannabis sales at
this point because you know what the
[__] is going to sell you sell one of
the biggest spots here and you're the
buying you're the buyer you do
everything you're the relations you do
the vendor right now got [__] every
single thing you need the shit's ready
to go your CP your genetics your thing
what separates you from everybody
else what are you doing different I
would say the time and the love you give
to it now it's just everything is so
commercial now and the game is so [__]
up bro you know I feel even bad for all
these new people that are I mean not the
new people but I feel bad for all the
the the real old school Growers that you
know what I mean the small like the mom
and pops [__] ones because you know
[__] bro that's where the real shit's at
bro mhm you know I mean versus Mass
operation yeah and you know and you
can't be mad at the mass you know what I
mean because I mean if you started way
back like you know like like my boy he
started way back and right now he's Mass
you know what I mean but you can't be
mad at that because you know [__] bro
that's where he's at that's the point
where he has gotten to but I feel bad
for like the smaller girls because they
they give a little bit more love into it
because you know [__] it's not mass they
only got a they only got a [__] uh
100 ligh or a 50 lighter you know what I
mean but you know I think think I think
those are the better girls honestly
right now because those are [__]
those are putting people are putting
more time into them you know I mean but
they can't last on a wck market but they
can't hang at the market because the
market is just [__] it's just too
[__] too fast right now bro black
Market's coming back in a strong way
that's why because of that reason the
black market is but at the same time you
got a lot of people in the black market
that are just [__] [__] it up bro
oh come on man where's that $50 pack at
they're still with that [__] using
that fos and all that crap and [__] [__]
you know what I
mean so you know what I mean so
it you're talking about weighing it down
bulk B Mondo Burger versus good burger
remember good burger in the movie
remember Mond Burger there's just GMO
[__] big burgers that's how I always
describe it and it makes sense you know
they just be [__] up the prices now
because it's just so much [__] weed
everybody oh [__] it's legal [__]
everybody's trying to grow now and guess
what the people that [__] up and you
know don't do the [__] right and guess
what they're Sig packs at [__] $800
$900 here you go the [__] now the
market just [__] whack bro like
nobody knows what the [__] okay well I
got this for yeah but you could bring
out something good and then you know
[__] this guy brought some whx [__]
but his price is just [__] makes more
sense with [__] the way we're flowing
right now with the economy and [__] you
know what I mean it's like [__] why am I
going to go spend $1,300 on a [__]
bomb ass pack right get this [__] for
$800 because this guy grew it it's still
good it gets you Stone but they just
don't know what they're sometimes too
you know what I mean yeah a lot of it is
just uh no experience like it took a
long time I would have bought the
[__] cheaper pack back then if it
looked pretty I would have bought like
bro look at this you know how much I can
I can flip this there was times at times
where you be growing some [__] some
weed and some outdoor [__] and sometimes
you know you grow so good that it look
like indoor and guess what you get the
same [__] remember people try to pass
off remember people try to pass off deps
in oh yeah and they would sometimes pass
no sometimes where it would yeah [__]
sometimes where I made may have not done
that there's a pack that you get for
1,200 and you [__] flip that [__] at
24 23 yeah bro for sure you know what I
mean you make $1,000 off a [__] pack
and you you know [__] five pack 5gs damn
Green Day you know what I mean
yeah what's up with the new farm bill I
don't know but YouTube loves weed sales
talk yeah they do with the new what the
farm bill I don't know that shit's uh
the farm bill is like for alternative
choid C uh the stuff we do it's just a
farm bill that makes it legal they're to
reevaluate it soon so I don't know I
honestly you think all laws would be
moving in the direction no of course it
is and it is it is that's the future it
is because I mean but a lot of TC Brands
I'm not going to say like for a fact but
a lot of people that have skin in the
game and wreck market and weed are going
to be lobbying against it to make it
illegal to have TCA and HC for sure it's
[__] up their sales yeah I get it it
is but what about the people in the
states that can't get it 100% because
they need it so 100% mad but those
people are mad at that cuz it's probably
they're looking at it as a remember when
we were kids like damn those FS are
money hungry they kill somebody remember
those movies like damn they guy shot
somebody because he was messing up his
company those fools are real you know
what I mean you know what some of those
guys do that don't do that they Lobby
against your [__] that's that's like the
legal way of like I'm gonna kill your
company versus I'm going toal
connections yeah just use your [__] I
get it I totally understand I I
understand what it is [__] up their
their money but some people can't get
[__] and that is the point
and some people want sh shipped to their
door not everybody wants to go to the
store yeah for sure or get their their
homie has been selling them for eight
years that sells them [__] debt pack
at indoor pack maybe they don't want to
go through through that anymore yeah
true that for sure he didn't realize was
do agree I agree on that those [__]
those [__] but yeah so the the farm
bill I'm not really sure what's up but
hold on so just love and attention to a
plant that's all all we got out of that
I mean [__] I mean there's a lot of [__]
I mean I don't know no like what would
you drop what would you drop like right
right now every I'd go back [__]
growing with soil bro with soil old
school nutrients [__] you know what I
mean [__] liquid [__] no and and
getting the good strain too you know you
got to always have that strain too some
good OG's that's it bro I mean I think
[__] OG's it bro I mean [__] I mean some
good OG and some good what [__] it throw
some jack in there because you know some
good [__] sativa I would [__] with
the Jack you know what I mean how big is
the right size to keep the quality right
what do you mean like you're talking
about like oh this is age
restrictive try to sugarcoat this answer
like
done you know what I'm saying I know
what you're saying for this like his
shirt let's just say like this his shirt
thousand thousand lighter to provide
what you need for these stores oh Jesus
Christ that means you're cropping every
what two weeks every week every week
yeah there you go cropping every week so
every three months like it takes three
months to grow well there there's what
12 weeks in that yeah so we started 12
at the same time but a week later so
every week we're groing it's kind of
awesome the way that [__] functions and
it takes a lot of brain power to
function and plan this out and know what
goes where and how many people in the
schedule and this and that so I'm saying
like you you know what you're doing you
know you know what's going on real bot
iness [__] right it's crazy dude it's
crazy because you know the the growing
aspect of it but I mean I mean let's
just say there is there is a lot of good
weats still no matter what like even I
I'm even surprised like you know [__]
I'm smoking right now you know what I
mean that we've grown and it's like oh
[__] this [__] is good it's grown like
you know a lot but but it's just still
you know you still miss that old school
[__] soil [__] old school
[__] a plant that's been giving a lot of
attention and you know it's just like a
fruit bro when you taste the [__]
fruit off of tree like when people say
oh [__] your oranges are [__] bomb
they're so sweet and good same [__] bro
you know what I mean mother [__]
people be [__] having some [__]
oranges that just [__] taste like
crap why cuz I'm more into growing a lot
more oranges a lot more [__] you
know what you little [__] what you
laughing at you little [__] my oranges
are so sweet and bomb that's what you
did it just made me laugh I love your
oranges are so sweet and bomb well I
mean yeah you know what I mean [__] I
remember my my neighbor [__] she used
to [__] grow all her fruits were just
[__] sweet and good and I'm like damn
I never really taste a [__] till to and
I I would always watch to say what does
she do it's so different nothing bro she
just [__] went out there just gave
love [__] gave attention to him every
day [__] did her little [__] whatever
she thought in her head was good for
them and bro it was like it's like a
it's just like raising [__] a human
being you know same [__] Bro [__] you
know he's he's trying to leave out key
points when I would drop him off on the
weekends for his mom's weekends when he
was a kid I'd always give the neighbor
some nutrients but yo your oranges look
a little damn they look a little a
little white I need to give you some
[__] every time I come back
Plum and sweet and orange and then as a
kid Dad Dad and pick him up like yo I'll
see you on Monday put him down sock no
no I'd hike his socks up he'd pull out
his little comb for his mustache like
man I'll see you Monday like and that's
why he cut his hair cuz he was tired of
me giving him a noie every every Friday
we're going to fix that
floor we're going to fix that floor
don't you you know what's weird all I
imagine do you remember that one you
that stupid what was that little man
with Damon or Marin Williams yeah when
he was a full SI body siiz man's head on
a baby that's all I imagine this guy not
like little small like a baby version of
this yeah yeah wow yo that [__] smelled
like not great what is
that good [__] hit it I will hit it it's
still on it's still on hey drink that
water you got a piss now
[Laughter]
hopefully
not hey hey as Trey I'm pregnant how do
you know I got 11 kids this one SI water
he has a piss already it's
crazy that's what happens when you don't
have B had the genius idea we need to
convert these into ashtrays just yeah
cuz earlier remember when I was ashing
it right I asked him to stop baving all
his grinded weed everywhere I was like
put your stems in there and he throws
them in the [__] hole the hole that
leads to the ground
it's a mic hole it's not an ashtray fing
been ashing in the hole that leads under
under my feet a shoes are under here oh
so are yours and where do you think your
legs are where do you think your
legs it's a hole it's a it's a cool idea
it's a
hole Jesus Christ yeah I don't like that
it's cool do you want to try this lemon
uh what is it epic lemon no lemon poer
lemon power yep have you tried the thca
yet no oh I got it for you you can take
it home I haven't I was I was I was
actually wondering what that tastes like
taste it you're going to be very shocked
yeah youve seen it or no uh yeah I I
think I've seen it right you show me
Rosie can you do me a favor didn't you
can you go right here and get the Lemon
Cherry
bag the stuff that he loves he loves
purple flavors dude I have one purple
one right here is all I [__] with right
now what is it [__] damn a white jar the
last time you saw a white medicine
bottle J I don't think I've ever seen
one dude this is some good [__] right
let me
see all right yeah
let are you [__] kidding me this is
what you're smoking this is what I'm
smok this is the water that you serve to
your players this is all I'm smoking
right now this
yeah bro I can smell it and you can
smell it let's roll it up let's see
let's have Marty taste it and then what
I mean I'm pretty sure it's not even
flushed want to bet you know that smell
we see the ash right up the sh the as
white then it's not flush you know that
smell what I love it it's right here
it's the purples that aren't flushed
well no no I you know what I'm saying
the same thing yeah but no it's not like
that I know what you're saying you know
what you smell it right yes okay don't
deny me be like I agree with you but
it's not let me know I'm not crazy this
is not it I'm so happy I know you want
to roll it right now might as well I
have
ch no I'll roll one up real quick I'll
roll it up in seconds my boy you give
him all the stuff so he doesn't put I
was about to break it up on my oh man he
told me he's he's don't don't do it on
my desk and then look look at all around
those [__] things everywhere look at
me look at me W Marty did he yell at you
Mar this my thing that's side of the
table you little [__] jerk what is my
side of the table no but not before we
start the Hamilton stash that's when he
packed you a ball look at my side of the
table though OG what you look
what lick it lick your hand now
no yeah I'm meticulous watch this you
little [__] jerk off all right what
were we talking do we have any more fan
questions one last fan question here all
right here we go hold on hold on to
listen yeah okay listen decent looking
hunk of a man what the [__] oh that's
his
name I was about to say I was about to
say wow okay thanks man no no not thanks
I
know not thanks I know what's OG's plan
uh in a zombie apocalypse oh [__] I'm
I'm hitting this the first guy house I'm
going to I think I would imagine he has
a
plan bro of course I do don't
incriminate yourself I mean [__] just be
prepared ready [__] um put the mic
closer to you I got um just put it
closer to
you don't say stupid [__] yeah how about
that how about that don't yeah I got a
how about this we leave it
as I'm ready for the [__] zombies
I'll tell you that that's it I'm ready
zombies don't scare me that's gangster
that's so wild you're talking about the
zombies this morning as I was driving
here we were spacing out thinking about
zombie [__] and I thought H you seen a
zombie no I was driving here this
morning and I thought some zombie [__]
huh and as I was Dy to go i cho one of
these [__] in half and tied to
the roof of my truck and I put zombies
all over my truck and then no it's when
we're watching this movie that movie
last night and I was like oh was all
dirty and dusty no we were watching a
movie that had nothing to do with
zombies by the way that movie we watched
last night and uh oh 21 days listen to
words I'm saying in a zombie apocalypse
I would never keep my car clean and it
would always be dirty and dusty and
bloody so if fools walked up they'd be
like oh that [__] don't even work I
don't car you don't even let me [__]
take a drink in your car you get spill
[__] so what happen are you going to let
me take a drink in your car that day
before yes in the zombie apocalypse sir
I don't care you're going to be like
yeah bring your drink or you going to be
like throw your drink out OG you know be
funny what if in the zombie apocalypse
we're running from zombies and at the
end go hey don't eat that in my car for
what are you doing stupid that' be funny
you would [__] do that you know it's
just you though right yeah I know you
little [__] it's just cuz you have a
track record of batting 100% of ruining
[__] in my car that's not true oh my
[__] where the you get that
from I have video evidence of you
burning a head size hole in my seat and
then saying my cousin works for Honda
I'll get it fixed I sold that car 4
years ago dude cuz I knew you were going
to sell that car I sold it four year 3
years after I know because I knew going
to sell it so I was like dude wait a
minute he's going to sell my little
sister drives it she one he's going to
sell this car why am I going to fix it
[__] just kidding actually no you know
what it was bro on everything in my
house my my boy my boy at Honda was in
at Honda remember he passed away
seriously [__] serious [__] stop serious
[__] he passed away bro I'm not denying
even lying about I'm not denying that
yeah so I couldn't get you the the [__]
you said my cousin works at Honda no I
said my boy works at Honda you said
cousin
Andor I tried getting home of my boy
[__] they're going n bro you're he
passed away I was like [__] I was like
damn no car seat now that's [__] up
that was [__] up that was [__] up o
just made up everything that was really
cool no he did I'm not lying though he
really did pass away well that sucks you
know what else sucks suck your track
record for ruining [__] in my car just
OG getting out early dropping the entire
[__] Cherry throwing it and walking
out of the the car which was wild which
was which was nuts that that that he
chose to do that instead of just carry
the tray out and throw it on the ground
no it wasn't accidental bro and know it
was accidental but but guess what I woke
up that morning thinking it was going to
be a normal morning right uhhuh this guy
says no we're going to smoke a joint in
my car and we're going to do this
so whose fault is it
[Laughter]
now GL he's not abusive and beats a [__]
like I woke up this morning expecting
potatoes and [__] don't get mad at me if
I punch you dud I did I was like you're
a [__] cult leader bro what's wrong
with you giving chimmy chungas to kids
if I choose to hit you it's not because
I don't like you when I woke up this
morning I didn't plan on hit I plan on
hitting you I didn't right I mean dude
it was your fault if I hit you it was
your fault bro right yeah
but no we're good don't trip I'll get
you your seat I the
car yo you know
what let me get that seat let I'mma put
in my living room a h chair there you go
watch There You Go video you guys did
when you first got the mayb back that
was I felt your stress when you guys
were hot boxing I'm staring at him like
this trying to do the video like y you
good you got it you got it you
good Ash my hand if you need to you saw
what happened earlier stop he cleaned
the whole [__] tray off because like
Thomas how you going to give me your old
weed on a tray and expect me to roll he
dumped the whole tray and went like this
and I went
stop the [__] guy was just going to
throw it
down what's wrong with him you saw it
though right and I went stop and he went
well what do you expect went I'll give
you an ashtray and then Marty would just
give it to me and then threw it in the
trash bro seriously he wanted me to roll
that [__] with my weed no he didn't it
was all in the corner Marty was here
hold on stop Marty was here Marty's here
he has to be biased it was the bougiest
thing I've ever seen in my life C I
don't I know I'm seriously I got
millions of Trades at home and I never
used
one good for you so this guy handed me a
tray today oh it better be a clean tray
you know what I mean was
all his STS and [__] like what the [__]
[__] out of here with your stems food if
you're going to go out of your way to
use this tray yeah you got be tip top
shape AR for sure
yeah that's crazy it's cool all right
let's continue I use trades for [__]
everything at the house yeah I know cuz
you're a civilized [__] upstanding
gentleman this man over here is [__]
ashing and throwing on his pants rubbing
it in are you somebody that constantly
loses your keys and
[Laughter]
wallet
know where sh at okay no no I don't [__]
no [__] out here I don't know where my
sh I'm tell you I lost my [__] key
yeah I did lose my key just about a
[__] a month ago and it [__] got
it got jacked by the [__] [__]
waitress [__] at ihob you know what I
mean he still wait you never found it no
I paid about 600 bucks for a [__] key
damn but I left it there just like you
know the phone got stolen and the
[__] key got stolen you know I mean
wa what are they going to do with the
key
I don't know she just said no not that
what she going to do with the key it's
just like [__] the key if I say we found
the key we've obviously found the phone
so she wanted the phone so [__] it throw
the key away I got the [__] phone
sell the phone [__] but yeah [__] we
lost a at IH I was at IH about a month
ago and [__] like that's why I [__]
oh actually when we went to the [__]
fight that night after the fight or in
the morning or you know what or you know
what maybe I I thought maybe it got lost
at ihob because they [__] jacked the
phone too but it could have maybe fell
too at the casino I don't know who knows
it might have might we went to go watch
the the fight the MMA fight mhm that
night and he was like you want to get
food I'm like no bro I'm good nothing's
good right now he goes you know what
nothing Good's open you're right I left
at 2:00 in the morning and the next day
I called him he's like I went to IHOP at
3:00 in the morning and if iuck I lost
all my [__] that's a bad idea if you're
going to lose all your [__] you
shouldn't go to
IHOP get more sober man then go to IH
have n just [__] [__] it [__] you
know it is what it is my point was if
you lose all your [__] in the house
though keep all your [__] on a tray
that's what I do Keys wallet everything
goes on everything goes on a tray as
soon as I get in the house I mean I want
do time but I'm pretty good at where I
leave my [__] I'm horrible you don't
even have shoes on where are your
shoes this [__] guy bunch of fans ask
for a sock check a sock he wears STS
trees tree socks I don't wear white
socks anymore you know what I mean I
used to wear white socks
well I don't know [__] yeah all my
lap used to wear white socks now it just
converted super right purple cape or
some [__] yeah let's get on to let's get
on to some something else I wear black I
wear white socks I I wear I wear white
socks [__] he's over here smoking a
joint white socks right it wouldn't look
right to see if I saw OG in some shorts
and some [__] socks that weren't wet
I wouldn't feel right this fo this full
we silk socks I think I had a picture
right showed him where I'm [__] white
socks white shorts Cortez yeah yeah I
have it in my phone like 13 years old
it's funny cuz when you call me it's a
picture of that one I edited of him
remember no call me no no no that wasn't
it call me though real quick [__] that
use your phone show everybody it's funny
FaceTime no call call me want to see
what OG's face looks like you got you do
I edited the whole thing it was just a
picture I took off I took off his his
mom's
don't FaceTime me call
me I can see the
icon oh yeah [__]
idiot stupid ass his [__]
[__] that's the [__] perfect 21
Savage's album came out OG wouldn't stop
playing 21 Savage so I put all a bunch
of tattoos on his face and a sword in
the middle second grade in that picture
he was actually 19 years old still
dressing like that OG didn't get his
beard in and his legs didn't grow till
21 then he shot straight through the
floor almost lost the
foot all right here we go question
yeah what separates you from every other
weat now I'm just kidding we already
went through that [__] didn't go
anywhere [__] [__] so loveing
attention What Separates Me from my no
no no we're not going we're not going
anymore we're not going anymore man
[__] God Jesus Christ all right here we
go have you ever finished one of the
episodes ever uh what do you mean what
have you finished have you ever finished
one of the episodes that you're
on [__] maybe the first one you finally
got through the first one from three
years ago first one yeah two and a half
years ago watching myself the cret
episode probably I don't know with this
I don't know it's like interviewing
Homer Simpson it's just like it just
feel weird
watch I'm like you know like I watch my
[__] and ler I'm like who the [__] is
this guy did you watch it with the live
chat going that's the way to do it who
is this guy hey N I don't know I just
watch it after I'm just like right you
know I don't know just
something it's [__] weird yeah ready
can't what's the most wild and carer
you've had running the dispensary in LA
Downtown maybe a few I had at C no one
that one that mattered I can remember
one where a guyy just getting stomped
the [__] out getting dragged out by all
those fools I remember that footage we
won't talk about that one but you know
what I'm talking about like wild [__]
has happened [__] I mean I've gotten
people in there try to tax me I gotten
people in there you know [__]
um [__] a girl in there [__]
literally hanging on her boyfriend like
while she's old and [__] like yeah let
me get an e this let me get this and
this girl just like [__] all over him
bro I'm talking not like [__] okay no
bro this girl's hanging down all like
dragging down all the way down to his
leg like he's a pole or some [__]
[__] in between his leg What the fu
[__] yeah bro some way off [__]
[__] Bro some way off [__] bro like if
she was a snake going through all his
body
bro [__] crazy [__] I got the video
still but you know I would just standing
at the counter just yeah I know dude's
right there and it's this girl bro and
this girl's just all over him bro like
[__] she didn't even exist only you
see it she's not even there I mean it's
way off [__] bro we just like way I'm
imagining is like an actual person sther
slithering on some that's what I'm
thinking bro on the floor going through
his legs what the [__] crazy [__] bro
was she tripping out or was it like yeah
she I don't yeah she might have been I
maybe should on some [__] uh ecstasy
or some [__] I didn't say that 30
seconds ago some kind of [__] you know
she might be on something some Dr that
makes her feel good like that you know
rubbing against [__] you know crack
whatever just crack crack maybe did bro
look like this was normal like yeah he
didn't care he was still right there
like yeah you know and then after he's
walking and she she's hanging out to the
leg dragging on him bro dragging him
dragging her out she say anything no no
[__] home girl is just [__] like a
[__]
like if dude who knows what the [__] she
didn't say a word that's cool just some
weird [__] bro but she gave her ID to
get in kissing yeah so she had to go
walked in and then next you know she
just in there like [__] she turned she
did she think she's like yo these fools
are sick I'm going to hook him up with
another eth or some [__] maybe that's
like their thing some weird [__] bro
that was weird that was like one of the
ones like oh damn I wanted to post a
video cuz I know that [__] would have
gone right viral and probably still will
you know what I mean that [__] pretty
funny I want you guys to see this right
now but you know like N I don't want you
guys to see
this what you do right there m the
joints you haven't even [__] finished
and you're lighting up I'll smoke them
right now after are you sure yeah all
right here just want to make it known
that's how I do it are you sure I like
to take bites of everybody's sandwiches
and then I'll finish all the sandwiches
in the morning I just take nibbles yeah
I like this I like eight different Meats
what the [__] you say I think they get
heavier bro honestly when you when you
let sandwiches C up a little yeah the
meat getss old I love it I mean
seriously you wake up in the morning
smoke one of your roaches [__] it hit
you harder than your [__] joint
in I don't know why you say that just it
just does I don't know that's just the
feel I get this a better feeling I'm
like [__] I could just hit you you know
all this [__] just double
how how wow how it's double how is your
phone still on
oh bro turn your
it's just an emergency it's not if it's
an emergency it's going to do that bro
let me see what's on your pH I can't
help it citizens app no give me the
picture let me see the picture give me
the picture let me see it do you see
this look at this look citizens app look
at
this that's crazy what is that it's not
crazy it's like a star Oh Oh you mean
the oh yeah crazy that protects me
weirdo it's my protection all right
he was still explaining how it's heavier
though as a as a roach that was going
off yeah right it starts going up and
the roach Just Hits Me Harder nothing
happened all right drink your Apple
Juice oh there you go there you go I'm
almost done right there yeah I know man
you've been pissing pissing a lot okay
what other what else has been happening
at your store besides girls [__]
having sex on the floor with their
boyfriends dry humping and you allowed
it you're like yeah yeah no it's cool
well I mean bro I mean [__] I mean she's
not really bothering no but she's on her
man what the [__] am I supposed to do
get off your man wait [__] on the
floor slithering can you go hey stop
acting weird stop acting Weir it was
like you know you jump on someone she's
just like sliding off of it [__] just
rubbing all over him why I can't did her
face say I'm high as [__] I'm insane
I'm I honestly didn't look at her face
too much bro hold on real quick before
you I looking at through a camera oh
[__] they cameras we talked about it on
it goes zo blocks you can zoom in on we
can see text messages on people's
[__] phones when they're not supposed
to be on their phones type [__] you can
read phones if you want to it's wild I
can see everything you're doing it's
nuts but the reason I'm saying it
remember that crackhead lady that made
an outfit out of that piece of material
the other day that the lady that was
butt ass naked in the alley oh I just
seen her on the way over here oh [__]
really I was just like oh [__] you heard
me go I just seen a naked lady oh yeah
she was bully guess what she has a
little [__] one little r that she's
[__] trying to cover herself with she
makes a full outfit it's [__] fny
said that right now it's like an old
body net or stocking she might not even
be from here it was wild bro and then
she smoked crack remember she pulled it
out of like a piece of material yeah she
that was nut and she started roasting it
and that's where we're like yo what we
just thought it was fascinating we're
we're bird's eye view mhm top of of a
lady you know she's naked because you
can see her like her whole back is bare
you can see straight down yeah it's not
like we're staring at a naked woman
getting dressed it's at the top like
what's this crackhead doing oh she's
naked oh is she making a she made a
whole outfit and then just
immediately yeah and then what happened
we zoomed out there's a dude standing
right there watching her yeah there's a
old the crack just standing staring at
her we zoomed out more and we saw this
guy had been out of frame off frame for
10 minutes creepy ass fool just staring
at her and she's getting dressed we even
went like y this is kind of odd she's
getting
dressed H and then we started talking
like oh look she made an outfit so it it
kind of felt odd watching her make an
outfit but we it's like [__] you're
doing perod she just smoked oh she was
right in front of the grow yeah bro it's
downtown yeah she's right where the
people take their breaks bro come on it
was [__] up um that was why
content she it's sad she looked like she
was a nice person MH she looked like she
having a great time yeah she did she's
just like stoked smoking crack and
chilling I feel bad you somehow have
weed on your headphone right here I
thought ash oh that's a right there you
got
it all right let's go what else have you
seen besides crazy ass [__] at your
work have you um I don't know if you're
allowed to talk about employee stuff
because there was that wild ass [__]
that had to get fired I we probably
can't talk about it cuz you're you're
the manager but how about
this besides that [__] walking in and
doing that weird [__] on that guy what
else have you seen customers do CU this
is great people watching it truly is
wild people watching MH yeah well I mean
[__] I mean just recently
[__] [__] my daughter got [__] a bong
thrown at her you know missed
literally foot right I send you the
video right like that's right that's
right you know what I mean could have
[__] her up bro you know what just
some [__] weirdo [__] you know
what I mean just just on some weird [__]
um yeah I guess you know what I mean he
just has some [__] issues with him I
guess I ended up [__] you know I mean
[__] everybody checks in with their
address and it's just a coincidence that
dude literally lived like [__] three
blocks away from my house you know I was
like what the [__] so you know [__] it's
a small hood you know he tell everybody
knows everybody so yeah sure enough I
just went ask and and yeah sure enough
before oh yeah is this oh yeah yeah he
has issues fo he's always [__] trying
to beat up old ladies or some [__] or
beat up old people yeah always picking
on on [__] you know on the olderly
you know elderly and [__] you know so I
was like all right little [__] weirdo
[__] it you olderly sounds way better
than elderly yeah it does when you said
olderly I'm like why isn't it olderly
right way better of wor than elderly M
good point but yeah you know what I mean
[__] I guess he's one of those guys
that does that [__] but yeah we had to
[__] block him from the store and all
that [__] but that was one weird [__]
and um I get a lot of [__] weird
people [__] people would just come in
ask for something and then next you know
they come in I didn't ask for that
you're like [__] they said you
asked for this you know I mean you get
all kinds of different you know but then
again you got to understand you know a
lot of these people do have some pretty
sure they have some mental issues that's
why they're probably getting medicine to
fix himself so for the most part
sometimes we do try to like okay we do
try to like all right maybe he's little
[__] leave him alone it's cool we don't
usually ban nobody [__] if they're
just some [__] yeah unless they do some
like way off [__] we're like okay you
know but if it's a customer that's been
going there for a long time that we say
oh this customer spends a lot of money
yearly here you know sometimes we'll
reconsider and say okay maybe he was
just having a bad day you know let's see
what's up we'll try him out again and if
he does it again then we throw yeah talk
about [__] no the [__] the dude that
dude only been there [__] two three I
think it was the second time there even
if he's in there 100 oh yeah you throw a
bong dude that's you could literally
kill somebody bro I mean you hit them
right in the [__] in the head you
could probably kill somebody doing that
[__] so no that kind of [__] no but when
they get off verbally they get off
[__] they get off a little verbally
and yell and [__] sometimes we got to
you know reconed because you know
[__] people do have some issues and
[__] we are in [__] California is
[__] up you know what I me also if
you're a security guard and you ever
work at this full spot be
fast because the guy threw a bon and the
guy the security guard I'm like fire
that I even said fire that fool like I
already fired him yeah he was gone I as
soon I saw the video go fire that
security guard just cuz the reaction
time of this man was like the reaction
time of this guy like I should turn my
phone
off yeah I'll get to it yeah I'll get to
it bong hits the ground I think I'm
going to get I think I'm going to go
tell that guy to
leave he took 9 seconds to get to the
[__] situation I'm like bro what are
you fire him I would have thought
instantly getting stomped out the second
the guy who started yelling I would have
got up like I'm going to go do my job
what's up with this fool now the fo wait
to the ball hit the ground the pieces
settled and was like hey please don't do
that you good like what the [__] you
have a gun get up any I thought it was
funny that's the that's that's like the
one thing I took away was like yeah bro
I walked in there and this fool was like
right there k I I showed up quick bro
[__] he had just done it when by the
time I got there he was cleaning up the
glass you know what I mean so I I got
there in like maybe six seven minutes to
the shop mhm and [__] right when I
see came bro get the [__] out of here
bro what a dummy damn even me like I'm
very like his attitude about it like oh
he he didn't say [__] he didn't even he
just said all right he knew what's up
got his [__] walked right out bro didn't
even [__] didn't even I don't want to
hear it bro like I've seen the video and
you're [__] your whack is it a
situation where there's always crazy
[__] going on or not so much uh you know
while we're in we are in downtown area
we are you know in downtown there's a
lot of homeless [__] you know we a lot
of homeless people going around and uh
yeah sometimes we do get them for the
most part what I try doing if I see a
homeless pull up and you know they're
they're being a little you know like
they they want to leave I'll go out
there and I'll offer them hey you know
you want me to give you a joint you me
and they're like oh [__] yeah yeah you
know so I'll give them weed give them
water you know cool you know what I mean
I always hook them up with some water
just so they can you know maybe that's
what they need yeah and they they
actually do leave you know they feel
like oh [__] you just give me a water
and you're giving me weed [__] I'm out
of here and yeah and they leave you know
what I mean so I try doing that that's
that's that's my first thing I do I
don't I don't just straight kick out any
homeless person like that unless they're
going through my trash then I'll be like
f [__] out of here you know what I mean
but no other than that I'm I'm [__]
cool I'm cool Freddy cougar fingers over
there fing
barrels yeah man you
better give them some joints oh yeah
yeah I I [__] you know I don't Fu you
know being homeless is I don't know what
got them there so I don't want know so
you know I I don't know what it feels
like it so I I'll always take care of
them [__] it have you been firing the
[__] out of people like you were last
time but oh yeah I still do every day
all the time every day not every day
damn near I mean yeah I mean I do bro I
I constantly I'm firing people I mean
dude I run like over [__] a lot of
people yeah there a lot of people it's
over six people there it's a 60,000
Square you feet [__] it's a lot it's
like almost a whole [__] block MH it
is I got about 80 to 90 employees maybe
so yeah and I'm watching Everybody bro
so yeah if I see somebody on there some
[__] that they're not supposed to be
doing [__] yeah bro and it's funny is
they're going to be watching this as
they're working there because they put
it on the screen as they're like oh [__]
put my phone down and [__] as he's
saying that as he walks by and someone's
I got I got I got over [__] 150
cameras so [__] I'm watching
everything that's
sick everything bro I watch everything
ready yeah you guys are starting a
restaurant hopefully be
opened by the time by December wait this
comes out Monday this is not going to be
open it open tomorrow on Sunday sorry my
bad I don't know why my 24 hours wait no
I not even started by this year
by the end of this year all right that's
going to be awesome so we have
to do something for that we have to
actually do some like when you do your
opening and [__] launch you know what I
mean was just come and do a podcast
inside as he's cooking stuff well he's
not the one [__] could you imagine
though just like hey sh shut up fool no
fool talk about a ghost
story he ringing a bell hand people with
food [__] [__] ghost remember what I
called it if you ran the kitchen no the
burrito Nazi oh burrito Nazi yeah what
the [__] you ever seen Seinfeld The Soup
Nazi no these are key words to get us
flagged key wordss we're [__] dumb
but yeah hey fol hurry up stupid get out
what do you want next next get out
everybody scar as they order in in the
show you walk up like this you tell them
what you want you hand money you stand
over you get your change you don't say
anything you leave that's the ordering
you that's the way I feel at the shop
sometimes F when I have to go out there
and butt 10 because I just see a big old
line you know want to go out there I'll
go out there and they're like all like
uh I want to get uh they're all [__]
like oh this just cheesed up on me
[__] freezed up right there he don't
know what he wants now you know what I
mean but yeah I do get those patients a
lot bro or like if I just tell him oh
maybe you should go with this yeah I'll
take that I'm like nah no no wait a
minute what do you like to smoke bro cuz
that was too easy I mean [__] that what
do you like to smoke and they're like oh
I like this I'm like okay yeah that's
what I thought you need some sativa bro
here you go you mean I was about they're
about to take [__] IND the gun shell
like let me scare you into options n
dude but I do get that a lot bro I don't
know you know why though it's not cuz
he's like me or anything he's doing this
the whole time what do you want he
doesn't realize that this is
scary he does that to everybody in the
shot dude here's your
check every time when you walked in here
yeah you did see when you walked in here
he went got a gun missed all the targets
walked straight in it was crazy I just
wanted just to say the beginning of this
episode where I beat OG in the shooting
contest I would like to
say I win I won there's nothing you can
say we could do that every time you come
on now no I dude come on he has me a
plastic gun bro I'm expecting I know
when I shoot a gun I'm expecting a
recoil and [__] it's just
like like [__] what the [__] is this
[__] aim no literally I pointed bro and
the [__] [__] went up fool not
for me I just shot straight but yeah you
already you already knew how to shoot it
he handed it to me when you got here
Marty he had never touched it before
ever ever I even went oh there's orange
on it sick and I said I've never shot a
handun that's pretty good but no I was
just [__] what the [__] no Mari
thought brought this idea up right
before you walked in the door if you
look at it that that aiming is [__]
wrong if you aim it it doesn't hit where
it's supposed to I know when I go and
miss the Target too it looks
terrible [__] I was wondering why is
he aiming a little more down and yeah
and it's hitting the car a little more
down I was just doing this wait you know
we have video evidence of me going like
this really
really yo restaurant ready go this is
going to be you know I'll just you want
me to take it away or do you want to
speak yeah what's up what are you what's
your restaurant going to be like what
are you what are you guys serving what
are you selling we should talk about the
yeah restaurant by December it's going
to be [__] it's going to be a FL flas
you know what I mean [__] flas Mexican
food vegan food oh there we go there we
go this [__]
guy you know
spaghetti Italian food that's like how
the way you pit your new Italian
restaurant it's Mexican food flas yeah
[__] flas bro it's called [__] you
know [__] every FL that you could
think of bro it's going to be there are
you [__] me hold on would you say
the name was look at her face oh is it
is that what we're doing Max okay yeah
so it's they got hella vegan options
options and [__] both and vegetarian
for you because you like the cheese yeah
exactly well regular food like regular
we're going to have a little bit of with
the beef you know for my boy and for my
boy who you pointing at who you pointing
at for my boy it's your wife and Rosie
for my
boy all man we're going to have
everything yo ready go OG is going to
open up a a restaurant in the mon
monabell area and it's going to be
called veggie Max like he's been doing
they've been doing catering they've been
doing [__] they're going to be able to
eat regular food for all you people that
eat regular meat stuff like vegan's rare
So and they're going to have vegan
options because you can't just be all
vegan in toward East LA it's probably
not going to be not the demographic no
no but you're going to have hella fools
that will go because I drive to that
spot and E all the time to get vegan
[__] because it's bomb yeah so there it
is so it's going to be opening soon and
it's not just flas and every you sound
like [__] bubble gump right now you
just said flas and every type they they
have of flas those about it WR yeah it's
gonna be some good [__] man just just
stay on GNA be some good [__] just stay
on the lookout you'll see it I mean I
don't want to say right now where is he
going to you know what right now I'm
looking in the east LA area mon no what
I'm saying like where can they like on
Instagram do you have a website oh yeah
you can follow veggie me for now veggie
me on Instagram yeah all right for sure
you know sounds like a rap name veggie
mix yeah you sure what about veggie mix
make a commercial of uh OG doing like a
a you know like music video but it's
like a pitch you never seen low rob you
can watch him in any music videos [__]
you ever see him ride a skateboard and
chug juice oh my God
sorry we went to our friend's going away
party when he was going to jail right OG
was there when we were talking about the
Superman or the invisibility that's what
we talked about it oh
yeah remember Rosie the stripper girls
we were talking to and like your is like
he looks familiar I go you mean dog face
and she
went I it's not him she just started
dying how [__] hard did that girl
laugh she she loved it she went is no
it's not holy [__] he looks like dog
face I'm like it's dog Face's brother no
she for a second believed that was dog
face that's not what happened she
literally went is no it's not she knows
she goes dope as Yola's daddy she knows
the whole [__] but she went with
she's like oh yeah he does look like him
but daddy said she said your friend
looks familiar
[__] I didn't say
[__] and then I said
dog yo what if next
time what if next time we invite OG on
the show we
also invite a do face so when they both
walked in the room together they' just
break dance competition no it's like
look at each other we stare at each
other great T
competition no but it's like we down
each other he sees his own shadow yeah
exactly that's what it's going to be
like [__] up fool what's up what's up
what's up what's
up it just never stops so they glitch
out stupid this [__] guy then we find
out they both robots skateboarding
dancing robots yeah it's like a mirror
looking into a mirror into a mirror do
Infinity
air oh air I'm just kidding probably our
new accountant's name Amir
sorry all right what wa how you feeling
you want to smoke those roaches finally
dig them out of the ashes smoke this one
dust them off don't worry they're full
of Ash get with it use your Instagram
hey I got my Snapchat deleted I tell you
dude literally Snapchat [__] no you
know why cuz they're they're [__]
they're on it now F not like
before it the and [__] I'm not getting
nowhere near remember we talked about it
I told you right hold on that day I
posted is anybody Snapchat Shadow Bann
too and that one boom My Views like
normal and the next day got deleted damn
I posted the TAA pack in 30 seconds my
page was gone yeah bro I'm not even
posting weed on Snapchat crazy I used to
get about [__] what like
about I think I was getting about what
26k [__] 27k views on Snap bro and
and once I posted [__] the grow and I
was like what the [__] 350 views I was
like what the [__] happened here bro so
it literally went from [__] that many
to 350 views so like all right [__] this
[__] I just started posting like little
random [__] like just different [__]
just test it out bro it didn't go up to
30 30 uh it didn't go to my regular
views but it went up to at
least 10K 12K and I was like okay that
feels a little bit normal but not as
good it was but bro it's [__] they
they be Shadow blocking everything now
that's it that's cool I like it I think
they're done bro they're on it oh GE
told me the other day that he wants to
start his remember we talking about oh
you have your own podcast you're just
talking to a microphone by yourself and
all the terrible things that will come
of it
yeah I think he's talking about he
should do it I think he should do it
yeah I know I'm I'm gonna do it I have
it coming I have it coming but his room
I want surprise I want to surprise Mio
right here I'm he's going to be shocked
I'm gonna do it I'm GNA do it or he
might say it for seven years straight no
stupid I hope he doesn't I hope he
doesn't I mean I hope he does I mean you
know gamer [__] yeah no on some talking
into a microphone he's going to get
canceled so [__] fast it's crazy it's
crazy some of this World Views that this
guy has to be the point are oh yeah yeah
yeah I imagine I mean so like you old
white man from the south you you just
think so
old I swear to God he's going to take
it's going to take two seconds for one
[__] on Twitter to
go and they're oh he don't give a [__]
and that's pretty much it yeah I think
that's amazing 100% [__] oh no I'm do it
some of the [__] he said I'm going do it
for me right here cuz I have to I mean
honestly this guy's the one who's
[__] is pushing me to it because see
this guy let's go right how far along
have you actually thought this out like
bro it's been years bro this guy knows
it I think I told him before he started
his podcast oh I want to do a podcast
but you know what I mean he knows me
very well and was like [__] bro but he
knows I don't I don't have the balls to
do it because I'm [__] you know what
I mean this guy's really good with the
camera and [__] he was a kid when he was
a kid he was so good on camera get the
[__] out of here every time we had JC
Penny he's like sit up sit up and the
guy would go that's me right here that's
him picture he's telling us stories
about him you know he knows he knows
Daddy [__] you pick one clean idea
just focus thank I told Bill bur Monday
Morning podcast yeah one guy screaming
into a mic in the morning that's what it
is and this guy talking it's kind of
funny because the [__] that's gonna
happen you're it's going to be 15
minutes of footage with 13 minutes cut
out because the [__] that he's going to
say no you know what he should do you
should do the 10-minute podcast model
where at 10 minutes the outro starts
running and you have to end it you never
seen that well sass did a 10-minute
podcast ready us three it was three guys
right yeah and he explained it timer go
and once the timer stops the show's over
so you better get your last words up
what the that's way you know it's like
you have to get your [__] off in that
time all right and for the fan it's like
10 minute little pops no [__] I just
want to get us ready for the backlash of
when he gets in trouble online because
it's going to come to us get it ready
you should do it under a AI character
moniker no because you're going to know
his [__] name well I mean yeah
exactly I mean sh like I said I got my
son I got to go to say Meo what happened
and he just say oh dad you know this
this what you [__] up don't ever say
that
I'm say it
again some of the [__] some of the [__]
this guy says even I'm
like I say [__] for funny I think you
might have meant that one pie of [__]
hey man [__] that that's feel [__] that
F I'm from the ' 80s bro you know
[__] we say some dumb [__] or '90s
whatever [__] we do say some dumb [__]
you know what I mean but it's all just
[__] it's charact it's [__] it's
humor yeah I mean [__] yeah it's not
1994 no more bro we can't be dumb number
I mean [__] bro I mean I I can't help
myself you know I mean [__] you can you
do it
here but once you got all the Tik Tok
kids are going to be horrified oh no
they're going to have document
of the clips of this guy you know no no
I can't even talk about what he's going
to talk about on camera because that's
the what I'm talking
about and Queen Elizabeth [__] that bit
that she just say some [__] like that
she's dead and he won't even know she
died she died was going to be on no
world current events at all but he's
talking about current world events the
whole time the whole time I promise you
no I'll make it interesting I'll make
sure I it's going to be very interesting
I promise watching I'll watch every
episode I'm going to make it work I'm
going to make it work what if I mean
every third time you played video games
you [__] recorded yourself or
whatever like that's me when I play
video games I mean I'm not going to lie
the only word that I do use when I play
video games lot [__] no well
yeah but I mean yeah we can we can stop
we can stop whatever you're going to say
right now yeah how about that see what I
mean how about that see what I mean this
guy how about that how about I know what
you're going to say and let's just leave
it at that I mean it's not that bad bro
no it's not that it's bad it's YouTube's
stop some platforms are little [__]
fools when they allow guns and murder
and fools to smoke meth on C what's
another old school word for [__] just
say [__] that's fine anyway that's it
that's fine boom do you know what I'm
talking about do you have a clue how
about we just continue do you have a
clue how what I'm saying though honestly
do you yeah I think the whole audience
knows what we're talking about like [__]
mean in that way because I mean [__] bro
just a word that I I use and everybody
uses it I even they even use
it that's the end of OG channel right
there it's going to play lasted 2024
through
2024 that's all it's going to say
because you can't do that anymore you
know why cuz people are so sensitive and
soft but I give it about another year I
feel like it's going away fools are
saying [__] they want fools are saying
wild [__] again I'm BR bring it I'm
going to bring it [__] it we got to
bring it you're not a stand up comedian
Bro [__] it I am those fools have to be
the ones I am yeah they have to be the
ones who go on stage and say some wild
[__] for other comedians to start saying
[__] once it gets it get on the roll get
on the roll cuz streamers are doing that
right now but they just look like
[__] because no one else is doing
it yet it has to be like a [__] mob
mentality of that I think for people to
go hey shut up we can say whatever we
want just don't watch don't watch don't
watch don't watch but we can't do that
we're [__] we get played on this app
that's why I have to be careful with
certain words because if I could say
whatever I
wanted come on man it'd be a lot funnier
I think but it'd be like o that was
harsh but yeah funny you know what I'm
talking about yeah true you're right
yeah OG OG on his podcast you'll never
know
pantsless chest up but you'll never wear
pants that's his I get up and put my
pants on Juan burgundy yep Ron Burgundy
style yeah right Juan burgundy though
Juan
burgundy exactly you're on [__]
fire that was a good one um all right
cool good [__] OG how long we been here
about two and a half what Happ all right
we've been here for a while you told
full [__] stories tonight
today you told him in full detail it was
crazy
also watch his face OG's the king of
getting you into parties like he can get
you into any party for sure especially a
warehouse party where he works for like
you can walk right
in no
problems [__]
that I'm just kidding I went to his
party and took forever oh I thought you
were talking about the orgy party oh
sorry no I'm talking about this party
they just had it was a [__] because the
list in there I think you got me that
party you took me there we're talking
about the party from last weekend dumy
Oh that party yeah that was a crazy
party right no I wouldn't
know wow if my son would have just been
a little more aggressive and be like
[__] this let's go he would have got it
trust me I don't do that I know but yeah
you know I was like yo I'm on the list
and they're like we don't we can't find
the list yet I was like oh all right
where do you want me to park we'll take
it Valet Park right there I'm like all
right cool he took his car he went
around the corner I went nah I walked
around the corner in the depths of
[__] disgust ass part where all these
homeless fools were when they no
homeless drug addict fools homeless
fools they're just sleeping homeless
drug addict fools looking at me it's
Halloween I'm like damn a priest outfit
on he's homeless guy what the [__] walk
back yeah walk back four minutes later
like where's the [__] did they park my
car and I see the car pull up I'm like
oh hell yeah turns out his security
guard they parked my car under a freeway
by the
Coliseum because the parking lot for the
artist was full and his guy recognized
my car and went you take that car back
right now or OG's going to fire you and
I was like thank God they pulled it
right in front I I I went and do my car
to get [__] out of the trunk while we
were waiting in line that's how right in
the front perfect this what calls me I'm
telling them bro pull up to the gate
wait they're going to open the gate for
you that's I told tells me oh they just
took my car I told them they said oh
it's my [__] heart dropped right
there fool also and I didn't want to
make it I didn't want to make a SC to
this food so I was just like uh oh okay
I was like what the [__] and I'm
thinking dude no [__] way they
shouldn't have [__] took your car you
crazy so oh yeah some girl just some
lady took my car all the valet people
[__] bro I was I was [__] I was like
damn bro nobody's you're supposed to
wait and they're going to open the door
for you let you in told they said
they're supposed to open the gate on the
left I'm supposed to drive and they go
bro all of a sudden this fool out of
nowhere is like they brought my car back
it's back it's right here they parked it
in front we're good I was like all right
cool then the next day or after come
Monday my security I see my security
guard tells me oh you know your boy's
car yeah they took it all the way over
here and I was right there I'm like you
better take that [__] car back right
now that's [__] OG he's going to
[__] fire your ass that's his [__]
Boy Car you better take that you know
much this car is worth and bro that jump
back on the car took the car back not
even that it's like you're on the list
we're going to park you you and under a
bridge like what I would have parked it
across the street what's wrong with you
they take this BL
car the valley under a
bridge the [__] went and just found a
spot anywhere I could have did that yeah
for fre I don't know where it's at what
if she leaves for the night where's my
[__] car sorry as she as I was
process like wait [__] yeah [__] anyway
left that's crazy go down the I5 right
when you're going toward East LA and
then you see the city on the right like
right when you're on the five right
right where it goes to like the 10 and
[__] whole middle of my rim just comes
off flies down the [__] five I tell
you that did I tell you that OG my whole
[__] piece of my rim flew
off
[__] that was a [__] that's some
[__] my whole [__] Center hey tell
me this this is when you were driving
did you see the rim the side of you I
heard I heard I'm like that was a steel
rim rolling away wasn't it hey I lost
the hook cap one time and I literally
I'm driving and I see the hook cap
[__] passing me up I'm like oh [__] a
hook cap my [__]
hook [__] chasing it down boom pull over
get my hook no not even that the metal
No Cap the metal plate that gets put
into the CER cap it holds it in
[__] fell out oh [__] that [__] was
like custom right like special
order yeah it flew out and then I called
the guy I'm like yo I need this I feel
ghetto as [__] all you just see lug a
bunch of lug nuts with a big missing
play out one [__] and I'm trying to
I'm not trying to complain the car is
still cool you know what I [__] mean
like yeah totally like like in a Friday
like the scratch that didn't make not
want to drive the car exactly yeah
exactly G
God I know was it like a heavy piece of
metal it was as heavy as a table Marty
it's solid steel that's why I heard it
didn't oh [__] you're luy what if that
[__] would have bounced up through
somebody's windshield nobody was next to
me on the right as I heard it I looked
right like that was my [__] nobody's
there I'm pulling over pulled off saw it
just oh you did I thought it was my back
one so I went and saw it I'm like yeah
front the
front like the back a little better
[__] front's got all those lug nuts
showing I'm just staring at it like look
at all that oil it's
black coming through my room [__]
[__] it just hurt but anyway I called
the guy I'm like you know it's first
world problem bro be happy you can at
least get it fixed most people can't get
it fixed just be happy I called the
guy's like we just left to SEMA like
[__] the one thing time I need something
the whole company leaves to SEMA the
biggest the biggest car show everyone's
gone and I'm like oh good I'm going to
disart my car this week I think I don't
want to drive it like that it's just
like you know what I'm saying it's like
walking around with a zit right here
yeah yeah oh hey what I would do back in
the days if I had one of my hook caps
take the rest off yeah I'll no I'll take
this the only one side off so this side
was black Donuts the other side I look
cool that's why I told Rosie that's I
told Rosie too yeah it'll match you know
what I mean f it I told Rosie the same I
was like should I take the back one out
so one side matches but there just black
you see oil marks with see the Mexican
kicked in right there those Mexican
instincts bam he like what should I do
take the back one off and something take
your neighbors and [__] not even that
I'll [__] find stuff to carry and
stuff yeah I can make a lot of random
[__] so stupid [__] a I watched my
grandpa instead of use a jack my
grandpa's a
mechanic I watch my grandpa dig a hole
under the
tire so the tire would have room to be
free hanging and take the tire
off my grandpa Greg that's been driving
for 55 [__] years that's smart it's
the dumb he has Jacks for days we have
Jacks they're pallet jack we have wait
but wait but he was doing it on the dirt
so think about you can't do a jack on
the Dirk it's going to just seep in oh
it's gravel and dirt put some it's where
the Diesels are parked oh [__] heavy
heavy heavy diesels with trucks
Grandpa's a
dummy my grandpa is what you would call
weter mhm one time I lost the
dipstick I lost the dipstick yeah we
know screws in what did my and oil was
coming out I guess I took it out to put
oil and I [__] forgot to put it on
when I was doing a delivery and like
just lost it and I was like wow there's
oil leaking [__] I told my grandpa after
I was going to work not my grandpa Tom
my Mexican ass Grandpa Greg the scary
one the dipstick the oil is coming out
there's pressure it's going to keep
coming out what is did he do what what
would you do in that situation go to
O'Reilly or something just get a cap or
get a
dipstick what do you think my grandpa
did Mexican ass [__] he made his own
dipstick for sure yeah my grandpa did
this I went don't [__] whistle at me
what do you want to do just tell me what
you want to whistle I hate that
[__] don't do that [__] to me [__]
Mexican ass fool and then I'm like he's
like saying in English cuz he knows I
don't speak Spanish he's like let me say
it in English I'm like you could just
teach me too instead of just like
getting upset that I don't speak Spanish
I'm here teach me [__] anyway
this fool
goes right there grab give me
that I'm like what did you want a stick
for the fool started stripping the
[__] stick you know how it's still
alive he started stripping it of the
bark yeah and shoved it into the [__]
hole where the oil is just enough for it
to stick out then cut the top off yeah
covered it and there's a little bit of
[__] wood sticking out I sold my car
to Ralph's Auto Sales on 16th Street
with a [__] piece of wood in and they
said nothing and then what happened they
made me commit fraud well essentially
and they went to prison for fraud like
don't you say you make 1,200 a month
just put 2,000 it's not a big deal the
banks are going to approve it we got it
it's all good and then what happened
Rosie they had the video of them on the
new was running away from the [__]
car dealership as they got raided the
guys car dealers sprinting away from the
place bro like like like a drug raid and
cuz they they they played me I found out
later that my blue book was like six and
they charged me 10 he actually charged
me 11 and then you're a nice guy I'm
going give you for 10 I went bro thank
you I was a I was [__] 19 18 oh [__]
you know you know what I'm saying like I
didn't know what I was doing I just like
I don't make that enough money I don't
have down payment I don't have a
co-signer he like I'm going to get you
this car I'm like all right I got money
I can pay for it down
payment I didn't have I didn't have
credit and I had a yeah anyway I sold
him a car with a stick in it they didn't
care you know what I'm saying like they
were just going to do something Shady
with that car like yeah there a piece of
wood in here I'll take it sure they gave
me $1,200 for the car I paid $1200 for
the car what the [__] drove for [__]
four years yeah [__] it
right anyway
fraud my Mexican ass
Grandpa here you
go all right so you would go back to the
mayad let's let's sum this up you would
go back to watch
people I just want to go back to how
everything all started bro got you or
back how we all got separated or how we
all like [__] how we all Came Upon to
be who we are you know what I mean
that'd be sick you want me to text him I
I know a guy text him pH pull them up T
to pull up pH hold up oh never mind I
can't call you it was going to be you
you know what's funny is remember
earlier no no no no I turned his phone
completely off an hour and a half ago
look at your phone I turned it off when
I said let me look at your picture your
phone's off look at your phone is off oh
you little jerk I turned it off when I
said let me look at your picture and I
just shut it down I showed him he went
like this looked at it clicked it it and
put it down I thought I was caught and I
was at the end of the episode I'll let
him know don't worry they still got the
work done all right Adam and Eve bit
Apple smoke your weed smoke a joint
here's multiple lighters we're good y
know this guest is wild just sitting
here on his phone and [__] what the hell
he's getting real comfortable on camera
he's just like [__] start my own show
guys start my own show yeah thanks for
having me on guys my own
show they're scrolling Twitter and [__]
look at his old music
videos like that up for sure can we get
you reacting I want live reactions to
new music videos U oh man we can't he's
going to get this full in so much
[__] [__] with these artists
[__] stupid ass look like a clown
look at his pants bro put your [__]
pants to dog I'm like listen to you I
guarantee you he's going to get so much
[__] and backlash I guarantee for
sure I probably will and all these fools
want to come see me you know where the
[__] I'm oh my God bro this Fool's
mentality and attitude okay forg that
[__] I can see it all I can see all of
it it's going to be fun
huh it's going to be fun huh talk [__]
about all these artists he tries to get
promote his we company uh as he talk
[__] about him you a little [__] he
has a sold one [__] thing you know
that he com do an in store yet he hasn't
made a [__] post yet [__] this fool
you haven't posted up on your story bro
[__] out of here see that's what he's
going to say I haven't seen one post all
day look at
him as he drinks his apple
juice Marty so you know what what what
this is the last one guys trust no no
we're ending the show don't worry oh
yeah no right before Dan no no we're
we're ending the show right now end it
right no we're end it right now we're
end it right now you know else to say
don't you were going to go to the
bathroom you going to go piss no is
there anything no I was going to say I
have I have I have another joint you
guys well that's not what you're going
to say you don't have another joint yeah
no you don't yeah no you don't here it
is see Marty let's let's hold him out so
he pisses his pants ready real quick I
have to piss is there anything El I have
to piss is there anything else you
wanted to talk about I don't think
so no okay we had no notes we had some
fan questions you are coherent as [__]
this episode and you're like you're
sitting up hella good there you go there
this was about under the table pretty
good the OG I don't yeah like no that's
not OG that's a another one that's a uh
breakfast of Champs it's not flushed yet
or it's not like it's like PHS
premature that's pretty good is it still
wet a little it's perfect look
it it just it has a different taste
that's what you're that it's just a
taste that I I feel like it's almost got
like a earth taste yeah it does I like
that's what I like yes I love that [__]
maybe that's what I'm tasting it tastes
[__] planty it tasted like like soil
let me
thatt it's a good [__] it's a good
taste try it it has like soily taste
earthy taste
like why do you not do your
tips it tastes like a Portland
basement it tastes like moisture in the
air tast like moisture in the air you in
the woods no it tastes like a basement
of someone's house in Portland Oregon
for everyone out there in Oregon just
went oh you mean damp this [__] tastes
damp no it doesn't it tastes like damp
earth mean I don't know I mean I get I
get a different taste from it here you
go just dropped my [__] joint in the
ash look at this guy he just look at the
body of it what a piece of
[__] get out of here drop a whole joint
in the ass it's good [__] though it
tastes better I know she threw
it taste it it's going to taste better
now th Ash on it taste it I don't like
that weed really pretty good for me
tripping it's like eating green beans
uncooked I straight plant in green that
tastes like I'm eating the bottom of a
beant stock good no it's just that it's
just my boy been smoking the one used to
no you you've been smoking like some uh
[__] that has flavor Clementine that not
what Tropicana some [__] not even
close Tangi taste not even close
everything he's smoking no that's true
has a Tangi taste like Tangi like lemon
the lemon I've been smoking call Lemon I
like Tangi sh I SM I like the Epic lemon
you had that's different not the you
smoking I I don't have epic lemon what
was it you smoked out what is it was it
Sushi or what was that [__] lemon
poppers I just told you oh lemon poppers
yeah I don't know about lemon poppers
yeah the one you smoking you said you
like it it's got a good [__] it's got
a sick taste that's what you told me no
that was my
weed
all right you win all right you win eat
this don't follow you anywhere cuz you
don't [__] post no actually uh
there's nothing to send them to follow
me on Twitter follow you on Twitter so
you can get a every monthly post uh no
actually my Twitter was down I just got
it back so I could start posting on
Twitter why did you get your Twitter
taken down well because
apparently what did you say made a
comment that I
was yeah I said a comment on some [__]
and then you was it to a politician uh
some people yeah how did I know how did
I know yeah did you threaten them no of
course not did you tell they should die
I made fun of him I put a [__] clown
face in a circus house I put a clown
face in a circus house [__] they
[__] was that pre Elon or post it was
well actually I commented and then it
[__] no was it before Elon mus took
over or was it before he oh it was
actually before and then now it got
taken off and I didn't realize it now I
put I just tweeted I think yesterday and
it [__] went up I was like oh [__]
all right it's not saying Little X and
little [__] it said something like
you know like it wasn't uploading a my
[__] comment oh [__] I put a clown
face in the yeah bro a lot of people a
lot of people probably thought oh this
who's not posting nothing I wasn't D I
was kind of actually blocked good excuse
now I'm like I'm cool I just [__]
posted I you know I tweeted yesterday so
I'm good to go I'm like all right cool I
guess but yeah you can follow me on
Twitter I mean Instagram putt you know
what I watch Instagram so you know what
I mean um I watch [__] uh just it
just they they just been reporting my
[__] now so that's why I took down a lot
of pictures of weed because they're
[__] actually reporting me every
episode we talk about this it's never
changed you've never once made an effort
in two and a half years that's why I
said this is not even talking about your
I've been seeing what happens to Miho
right here Heine like 300 Instagrams so
I'm like [__] that fine my second one
Twitter's you all day Twitter should be
the place oh man yeah Twitter I I'm good
at but just sometimes you know it's like
the hardest grow account on there though
some people sometimes don't understand
my humor and they might [__] take it
the wrong way it's like [__] that's what
you can't really put your emphasis and
words and emotion in the text so maybe
you just don't no I don't you know what
I mean that's like saying this was such
a little
[__] and if I tweet and go this Fool's
OG such a little [__] you know how many
people are D this's about to fight
because they don't know because you
can't say it how about you put a video
up then yeah you're right right yeah I
am right right it's real emojis
face emojis I'm I'm going to try some
[__] let's see hit this see what
happens all right okay ready OG's new
book comes out with Steven Seagal called
who can wear more black
St sequel to my book called I can wear
more
M my neck [__] hurts you're finally
drinking some water oh you drink all
your apple juice do this put your lips
halfway down put your lips over the
and then just go [__] and drink it
hey you're the one invited me to that
party put in your body anything you
would want put anything you want your
body and the person next to you body
whatever you want switch
places all right here we go oh here you
[__] jerk godd damn weirdo got the
weed um well thank you for being here
thank you for showing up on [__] time
thank you for never taking any breaks
answering no calls saving the pistol
after all these things we appreciate you
we appreciate you are you going to be in
Expendables 4 yeah you sure yeah all
right and we're James almost everybody
we've had a great a great time almost
huh what did you say right now I said
[__] nothing bro you see what I mean
I said nothing [__] guy bro how was
it writing American me and directing how
was it directing you just literally
sound like what that's what you said so
I like what the what maybe I heard wrong
go for maybe I heard wrong I said thanks
Edward James Elmos for being on the show
right didn't he hear me he's in the new
Expendables really no he's not an action
star that's why I was saying it Edward
Jam almost I don't know who the [__]
that is either Edward J you ever seen
American me you ever seen standard
deliver let's not do this oh [__] oh
[__] yo no wait a minute let's do this
on wait let's do this you know what
discover before you got here Marty has
never seen National Lampoon anything
what right it's just a his alley it's
right up his [__] it's in my
awareness but I I'm going to circle back
to it now with the kids yeah Nash ando's
uh what the Wally World one was [__]
hysteric with John candy in it oh these
are good [__] Classics man yeah for
sure Vegas Vacation
watchet Fletch you talking about with
Steve Martin no cuz
old dude Chevy Chase right still haven't
seen that that's one movie people go you
haven't
seen I'm tripping I know I thought maybe
you seen fled all right seen you know
who chvy chase is yeah yeah yeah okay so
what movie what funny Farms maybe or
that's a old that's a old movie you
watch you watch any Chevy Chase movies
man of the house with John Terra Thomas
oh that's that that was okay that was
not bad uh the I'm aware of all so any
you never watch any cheese I've probably
skimmed past him on [__] USA channel
a couple times and watched a little bit
like I'm aare I thought it was like I
thought everyone our age had seen that
that's that's that's just one thing like
you've seen National Lampo right
vacation family vacation yeah I didn't
like European Vacation Hold on said a
money gra no no no no it was very
weird it was kind of
gross and I turned it off which one what
part would you was kind of girls where
when they were real close to the
daughter the 13-year-old
daughter and they made like a joke about
like oh you're my girl or something like
that got real close I went I I get it
that it was like the joke but yo too
much A lot of these child actors have
come out of [__] this [__] is too close
to what's happening I see fear in those
eyes like you know what I mean like oh I
think I can watch Europe vacation and I
just turned it off that was like the '
80s bro there was the like there was
weird [__] going on in the 80s and then
[__] you know the the newu that made
me feel weird dude it's just like have
you seen the video where [__] ready
beep sorry guys that was
a yo he just went Alex Jones Joey Diaz
on us started talking about [__] that
gets you just
deplatformed we're not rich like that
bro we can't just say whatever the we
can't we can't I gotta buy a house this
what has kids we have to buy houses and
[__] still when we own a block you can
start talking about whatever you want
fine fine the [__] that he just said is
the [__] that you talk about when you
don't have your phone near you because
you're like yo they're going to know we
know like I've seen the videos there
some weird ass [__] going on with those
act anyway this is what gets us in
trouble the first time we ever got age
restricted we were talking about this
exact thing MH season one first time we
ever got an a video that is actually
crazy exactly what happened and it was
called how we met our wives and we
touched on this subject for 5 seconds
and then went into stories about how we
met our wives and they got age
restricted for the first time so we
can't talk about that [__] you can on
your your [__] OG Jones sure Alex OG
whatever you want Jones OG Jones yeah
for sure OG Jones is kind of a hard name
your name should be OG Jones you know
who Alex Jones is he's you know we can't
even say him he might get his flag too
how about this don't follow G anywhere
on social media thing cuz he doesn't do
anything [__] out of here anyway he has
Twitter how we got there don't know how
we got in that big circle go follow his
Twitter Marty's Instagram and all this
stuff you guys know what it is it's boom
over the screen Marty made it my stuff
say say is my name dop all that [__]
guys OG doesn't post on Instagram go
watch him I post on my story comments
and I don't I can't really be posting no
more weed [__] no more because I'm
telling you it's getting report could
watch him like comments you know what I
mean say he's going to start his own
show to to get cancelled
quick quick oh man he's going have to
start his own website that's what that
he's not yeah you get on Rumble start a
Kick account or something CU you're
done before it uploads you're
done God this's going into this somebody
passionate subjects with no prior
research and [__] you're going to get
torn apart but in a good way you know
all the fools that love it I'll love it
I'm talking about like yo this is not of
business you are going to get
deplatformed
everywhere he's like yo I got seven
sponsorships they don't want to pay me
no more cuz have a platform like oh [__]
OG Jones is done just keep it a little C
oh you know I do got my YouTube channel
OG Kush 76 really yeah you have a
channel yeah is there anything on it uh
actually no I had to delete the videos I
had on there because you know what I
mean [__] you know what I mean I was
talking some [__] take some [__] off but
yeah I'm there and that's what I'm going
to be posting another of [__] let's go
okay OG Kush 76 there it is that's what
we're leaving with this OG cush
76 Twitter
restaurant great party
inviter we're done that's everything
don't run an apartment from
him never live next underneath OG Jesus
Christ also that foot bomb rip is coming
up right now this [__] you lost the
shooting contest you lost the shooting
contest we do a three shoot three
shootout with the basketball I mean
double or nothing yeah two two six for
ball ribs yeah you know make all three
you know I'll smoke you right I don't
take it you won't make one I'll make it
you think you're going to make three
shots in a row of course why would you
just say one shot I'll take your three
no no no no no you said three you said
three the best out of three you said you
I'm going to make three shots no no best
out of three no you get one chance no
best out of three no that's the double
or nothing we both best out of three sh
I'm not taking a shot I'm already
winning I have already won it's on you
at this point why would I risk anything
it's double or nothing I make okay
transfer your ballit what the [__] you
trying to finesse me make a shot it's
double or
nothing I'm not pay you $500 rent for
[__] $600 apartment you can't play me
on this all
right
got him can you can you do that right
now person look it you get one shot if
you make it you double or nothing let's
go right two bong hits out the six foot
bong though if you miss and it has to be
from where I say it can't be one foot
away one foot bong rip
one what [__]
is that's not how the Doubler
how about this six times less what hey
bro look do you want to double or
nothing right now you have to hit the
bong
once he's going to throw up all that
apple juice right into the B I'll hit
your bong so double or nothing or you
want just hit it um do you have I make
it I don't take a hit right okay yeah
I'll take the shot I'll take I all right
all right hold on we're establishing now
if you miss this shot you will take two
in instead of one all
right okay but if you make it you take
nothing yes me whatever you want yeah
that's do it let's go watch OG hit this
bong two times in a row he ain't making
[__] hold on and I get to pick where you
shoot from and I won't go 25t away it'll
be 8 feet away super close like a free
throw had some warm up shots 8 fet from
me to that wall at least really oh
you're [__] no cuz you are a cheater
and you go oh
you oh you're good okay I get to pick
where it's from do you agree to that at
least it's not what a corner shot you're
going to pick no I just don't want you
to be board be the backboard no look I
get to pick how far you are and it'll be
less than 10 ft no matter what for sure
let's run it I'm going to ruin this fool
right now two Bonet coming up I'll
change the water for you here we go guys
thank you so much for being here we're
about to B on out of here Marty thank
you so much for being here you sir OG
thank you so much for being here OG
Jones a piss fo oh hold on we're not
even done oh now we're done all right
guys thank you so much for being here
this been the dope as usual podcast
let's go watch OG hit the bong twice
throw up and that [__] was nasty you
guys ready cuz he ain't making this
[__] shot have a dope ass
day no what are you
doing right here right here hold on hold
on this is not a practice shot
do you want to par shop first I don't
one you sure this double nothing
situation all right
okay made it switch you want to go again
yeah triple another yeah I got you
triple it no no
no Miss no hold if you make this you
take one off if not I'll take one
off off right off B listen what's the
beted man what you want which one which
you want what you want I want you to
take three if you miss okay got you
three Triple B hit yes or no yes triple
triple you your Apple Juice smells like
liquor you
freak
oh good job good job you made it bro
good [__] of just focus focus you still
have to take
one now I'm good at this
this
face PR
sick pretty sick I get
this give one of these Thomas can I get
this one of
[Laughter]
these remember when you lost the
shooting contest I do here we go
smoke it
though
harder
harder oh my God you really
tried I thought you were going to take
me
up try good
[__] watch out watch out watch
out
[Music]
I forgot what a [__] monster this
thing
is yeah dud it doesn't seem like it's
much but [__] I can feel that [__] good
[__] that's what she said all right
[__] thank you guys so much for being
here this has been the dope as usual
podcast from OG's lungs Marty and I have
a dope ass
[Music]
day
perfect
[Music]